précis n'est
présente voilà laurent alors si tu peux
dire quelques mots sur les sensations
que ça va te faire de jo ici dans ta
région c'est toujours un plaisir de
jouer un bruit de bordeaux surtout que
c'est face à des adversaires très forts
comme alexei shirov michael adams donc
soit un très grand plaisir
voilà donc il a présenté enfin il n'a
pas présenté il a annoncé son deuxième
adversaire il s'agit du numéro 7 mondial
grand maître international anglais qu'on
ne présente plus michael adams
et voit la super star tant attendu
michael adams
voilà voilà le grand habitué des grands
rendez vous so michael you are here for
the first time in bordeaux
waters of feeling
donc voilà il est très heureux d'être là
et j'espère jouer du beau jeu donc c'est
ce qu'on va voir tout de suite je vais
passer la parole à l' arbitre alain sa
lettre qui va annoncer les couleurs et
qui va mettre en route les parties je
vous souhaite une très bonne demi-finale
voilà très bien donc le tirage au sort a
eu lieu dans l'après-midi la commande
que les volailles première partie le
maître michael adams a les blancs et
laurent frayssinet allées noires
je vais ranger sa
donc la partie va bientôt commencer
michael adams
2715 face à laurent frayssinet 2501
évidemment 200 points séparent ses
adversaires mais il faut savoir de toute
façon que laurent frayssinet et
redoutable qu'il a déjà battu des très
très fort grand maître et en plus qu'il
est vice champion du monde junior donc
laurent commence par une sicilienne la
sicilienne ouverte que michael ouvre
immédiatement par des deux des quatre
cavaliers g8 f6 donc voilà c'est une
défense nage dorff la partie ça ne dans
cette partie les joueurs ne prennent pas
du tout cavalier g4 c'est un grand
classique actuellement un grand
classique qui est joué très très très
souvent au top mondial donc c'est une
sicilienne nash dorff une position d'
attaque donc là les noirs ont
probablement je fous g7 oui et les
blancs vont enchaîner je ne sais pas par
quels coûts récemment le coup h3 été
jouée par par shirov contre un joueur
qui s'appelle guelph ondes au tournoi de
monaco donc je ne sais pas et voilà h3
donc le dernier coup à la mode qui est
jouée hk de se jouer avant et donc h3 un
coup à la mode qui a été joué par
michael adams il a probablement au suivi
c'est parti donc voilà laurent
frayssinet semble préparer
donc petite réflexion de michael f3 f3
évidemment donc il consolide son centre
il permet à son fou g3 d'avoir un petit
peu plus de deux possibilités en lui
donnant éventuellement la possibilité de
revenir sur la case f2 donc voilà je
pense que laurent frayssinet 20 soit
faire petit roxo calisesi cédric
cavalier b8 sait si c'est un coût tout à
fait naturel il se développe ses pièces
donc voilà hélas michael va peut-être
jouer fou et f2
ou cavaliers b3 fouet f2 voilà donc
michael défend son cavalier au centre
parce que la menace était cavalier prend
des quatre dames brand et katy et
cavaliers prend f3 échec au roi
lecavalier n'est pas perdu parce que
après pions vingt cavaliers le fou
aurait pu prendre la dame c'est pour ça
qu'il a joué faux f2 pour reprendre du
fou en d4
voilà donc dans cette position
laurent réfléchi
ce qui va être très important pour les
noirs ça va être de jouer assez
rapidement donc il décide de développer
ces pièces qui est une solution assez
judicieuse et en même temps de
de faire communiquer un petit peu toutes
ces pièces dont il contrôle le centre la
casse des 5 voilà michael réfléchi je
pense que michael a bien préparé cette
position
car il est quand même un grand
spécialiste de la sicilienne avec les
blancs et voilà donc bon avec michael
peu de surprises en général ils jouent
soit ce système avec fougue 3 qu'il a
joué contre eux en âge d'or soit il joue
des sicilienne fermé donc là comme si le
ciel ouverte il joue son système
habituel peu de surprise chez les deux
joueurs qui qui ne sont pas des joueurs
très con dire très surprenant dans leur
façon de jouer puisque en général ils
ont très confiance dans leur préparation
voilà donc
michael va bientôt jouer
non michael réfléchit donc voilà
donc
la partie a débuté il ya quelques
minutes donc voilà je
je vais faire une petite présentation
des joueurs donc à savoir que donc
laurent frayssinet qui est qui a
actuellement 18 ans 18 ans et demi il
vient juste d'avoir 18 ans donc laurent
frayssinet donc a été vice champion du
monde junior et aussi il a il a joué
plusieurs fois le championnat de france
nationale
il a joué plusieurs très très forte au
noir je crois qu'il a une ou deux normes
de grands maîtres donc il est sur la
course du titre voilà donc deux coups
ont été joués dans cette position d'amd
de haies dames 1 5
laurent fasciné un style bon même s'il
joue des positions très solide qui a un
style très tactique qui adore le jeu de
pièces le jeu de combinaisons ce qui est
assez normal chez les jeunes joueurs
donc quand un michael michael lui est un
petit peu comme ces charmeurs de
serpents comme je les décris tout à
l'heure c'est à dire il a un style un
petit peu soporifique quelquefois il est
capable de jouer des ouvertures pas très
agressive mais il les joue très très
bien et il les joue à la perfection et
il est capable de conduire une position
avec un petit avantage jusqu'au bout du
trade de manière excellente donc on va
voir comment il va traiter cette
position donc actuellement je pense que
je pense que les blancs
les blancs vont peut-être je ne sais pas
les blancs vont peut-être se développe
et peut-être sortir le fouet fin
ou alors proposé une finale parce que
grand roque est quand même assez douteux
dans cette position
puisque les pièces noires sont très très
bien développée donc actuellement on
peut voir quand même comme laurent comme
je les décris laurent a une position
très active il a encore un fou en
fouillant kétou c'est-à-dire un fonds g7
et donc il a un meilleur jet de pièces
mais il a quelques petits
affaiblissement dans sa structure c'est
à dire quand j'appelle affaiblissement
c'est à dire les pions h6 et g5 qui sont
un petit peu trop avancé donc voilà donc
pour l'instant
on va aller on va laisser réfléchir un
petit peu michael donc en ce qui
concerne les prochains rendez vous de
ses joueurs donc laurent frayssinet va
jouer au mois de mai un très très fort
tournoi de jeunes de jeunes joueurs ou
lille où seront invités les meilleurs
jeunes jouent les meilleurs juniors du
monde à lausanne d'ailleurs ce tournoi
sera comment dire verra la venue de du
du président du cio ça m'arrange voilà
donc fou de quant à michael 100
prochains rendez vous et le super
tournoi de sarajevo en
de sarajevo est il à sarajevo donc il va
jouer contre kasparov mais aussi contre
etienne bacrot le numéro un français
donc almira bonjour
vérifier est-ce que la pendule marche je
ne sais pas
la pendule ne marche pas vérifié un
petit peu donc voilà donc dans cette
position
donc dans cette position donc
les blancs ont joué fouet deux comme je
l'avais dit parce qu'ils ont développé
leur four il ne faut pas grand roque
parce qu'il s'est un peu tôt je pense
qu'il appelait blanc plutôt envie de
rock et du petit côté pour éviter tout
simplement de
de subir une attaque donc la question
c'est de savoir comment laurent va
prouver du contre eux dans cette
position parce qu il a des pièces active
mais il a une position un peu plus
affaiblie donc il va falloir jouer
quelques coups qui vont qui vont un
petit peu handicapé le le développement
des blancs alors je ne sais pas
peut-être cavaliers c4 dans cette
position puisque le fou et en russie ce
cavalier sekkat et
après
et après cavaliers ckpa cavaliers g6
donc laurent décide optent pour l'oeil
droit donc il libère toutes les cases
noires à savoir la case e5 f4 et h4 donc
comme je l'expliquais tout à l'heure
dans ce type de position le jeu de gaz
est très important donc les cases noires
comme ni à un fou g7 très puissant le
contrôle des cases noires est très
important souvenez-vous tout à l'heure
le fou de vlad même si sa position et
dans la première partie dans la glaise
même si sa position était inférieure le
fou de cases blanches a finalement
trouvé un avant-poste sur la case
centrale et ea était quand même très
très dangereux pour les noirs donc voilà
donc dans cette position cavaliers g6
donc que va jouer michael
donc je tiens de source sûre d'une
source
de source sûr donc que cette partie est
la suite d'une partie topalov qu'elle
fonde
jouer à sarejevo il y a un an donc voilà
donc
cette position est très connue
actuellement ce qui ne m'étonne pas de
la part de laurent est évidemment de
michael
donc
le jeune dacquois va-t-il tenir avec les
noirs nous le serons tout à l'heure
j'ai trois donc évidemment j'ai parlé
des cases noires g3 comme par hasard
c'est un coup de pions qui contrôlent
deux cases de cavaliers voilà je tenais
juste à signaler ça c'est que dans cette
position comme les pièces noires sont
actives la prophylaxie est une bonne
méthode pour éviter que l'adversaire
s'installent dans le camp blanc tout
simplement
donc mais laurent
à jouer que va-t-il faire
pour ces 8 voilà toujours un coût qui
optimise son jeu de pièces les noirs se
développe ils prennent la colonne s'est
évidemment c'est la seule colonne
ouverte puisque la tour de ses huit
jusqu'à ces deux n'a pas trop
d'obstacles évidemment le couple le
moins puissant on était peut-être tourbe
et 8 autour des 8 mai tour s'est vite
est un bon coup
donc voilà chaque pour l'instant on en
est toujours au développement
donc voilà donc une petite question
encore almira est-ce que puisque avancer
toujours l'invité du jour alors heureuse
m'a évidemment que je suis heureuse
bon c'est toujours difficile de jouer
des parties rapides donc on ne soit trop
grosse erreur et
celui là pour celui qui va faire les
dernières heures il va perdre
et quel est ton favori pour ce match
c'est un petit plus difficile de mettre
sur laurent mais bon c'est adams bien
sûr mais je pense que laurent ait repéré
deux tomes tu voudrais une finale 100%
française ça fait 6 mois
à 3 voilà donc la michael
prépare quelque chose là c'est un coup
alors il garde toujours la possibilité
de re au quai du petit côté roy a eu un
g1 est roi à 1 c1 on ne sait pas pour
l'instant tu sais pas ce qu'il veut
faire vont probablement peut-être grand
qu'un finalement parce que le petit rock
comme j'ai parlé tout à l'heure et assez
faible il ya le pion h3 qui peut être en
prise par le fou au cices le pion g3 et
le pion à f3 donc peut-être à 3 c'était
pour préparer grand roque éviter par
exemple pour deux oui c'est ce que je
pense je pense que dans les partis déjà
mentionné ils ont joué
rock cavale et b3 four b3 cb trois
cavaliers 5-fu des quatre je suis pas
grand roque il y avait des suites
possibles mais d'accord donc tu penses
qu'on est toujours dans une mine très
très connu oui pas très connu et je
pense que c'était j'ai une foi mais ils
topalov a gagné avec les humains topalov
ne pas confondre avec le chanteur
donc voilà donc actuellement
à 3 donc les noirs réfléchissent
laurent a encore chaque jour à cette
tique laurent a toujours l'habitude de
se gratter un petit peu derrière la tête
quand il réfléchit par moments quant à
michael il est toujours bien plonger
dans la position
donc laurent donc est né en 1981 et
michael je crois qu'il est né en 71 ou
72 je crois qu'il est à peu près de
71 je crois donc on a la même âge donc
voilà et donc michael et fait partie des
meilleurs joueurs du monde
il a fait partie des concurrents des
deux joël quand il était quand ils
avaient une vingtaine d'années ils ont
joué assez souvent ensemble je ne sais
pas qui est positif entre les deux à peu
près égale qu'ils ont annoncés mccaw
keven qui a pris l'avantagé même si joël
a quand même gagné des partis qui sont
magnifiques je me souviens d'une partie
qui avait été qui avait été
avait été fantastique une partie qu'ils
avaient joué dans un tournoi est ce
qu'on appelle un terreau n'allant 90g
pas en suisse voilà c'est bien je les
connaissais pas cette époque
donc dame à 5 e 5 donc là un coût tout à
fait central les noirs ont échangé les
pièces et propose une finale très
technique donc laurent qui ne se
dégonfle pas et il est prêt à jouer
contre un vieux routier un vieux
charmeurs de serpents il est prêt à
jouer une finale très technique donc on
va voir ce que ce qu'adams va faire mais
je pense qu'il est adam se va accepter
le défi c'est à dire comme la dame en
cinq attaques le pion g3 et la dame en
d4 il pourrait être logique d'échangé
les termes en cinq cavaliers prend 1,5
et d'essayer petit à petit de pousser
les pions parle de jouer à coup comme
roy f2 dans ces cas là c'est pas la
peine de rock et de placer le roi comme
ça et de d'amener les pièces de
développer des pièces petit à petit quoi
ça peut faire partie des suites
envisageable
puisque d'amd 4 f 2 n'est pas très bon
retrait je pense
et voilà donc une finale une position
très technique donc la force de michael
c'est à dire michael dans ce genre de
positions assez repousser les pièces de
l'adversaire il sait profiter d'un petit
avantage
par exemple le cavalier que lecavalier
qui à la place le support de la case des
5 mais bon la position est tout à fait
correct pour les noirs quoi donc
je pense que c'est ce que l'on pourrait
appeler un round d'observation c'est à
dire michael teste son adversaire il
veut voir s'il a une technique qui lui
permet de tenir ce type de position et
et
éventuellement exploiter la petite la
petite faiblesse qui qui va perdre qui
feinte qui peut être fatale quoi donc
dans cette position on va voir comment
comment vont jouer les blancs j'ai pensé
à roye et ce2 mais peut-être que le roi
doit être à l'abri je ne sais pas je
pense que la kf2 est une case
intéressante mais peut-être qu'il ya
d'autres coûts
donc voila sinon les réactions noir dans
ce type de position f4 sans attendre pas
la peine de placer droit il est celle de
chasser ce cavalier du centre donc là la
question c'est est-ce que laurent va
échanger les pions j'ai tout d'abord
puisque chaque échange de pion est très
très important et la deuxième question
sera de savoir où il va placer son
cavalier en c4 ou ou ailleurs donc voilà
les joueurs jouent très très vite je
trouve
la différence par rapport aux partis
d'auteur c'est que la tension est là qu
on dire la tension actuellement n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour c'est à dire ce
pas le type de position très très
complexe où il ya les dames et des
pièces très active là c'est plutôt une
position technique et
et pour l'instant les joueurs évidemment
ne subissent aucune tension puisqu'il
n'y a pas de pression de temps c'est le
début de la partie
donc tout est encore possible
donc voilà donc j'espère que
tout se passe bien sinon je signale nos
spectacles aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
peuvent donc déroulée la cellule de chat
et chatter en direct sur canal sur
www.camaieu.fr donc
et qu'ils auront donc les
les commentaires techniques et
est tout simplement zappé renseignements
pour le fonctionnement de du de
l'internet voilà donc cavalier c4 donc
laurent a décidé de garder ses pions il
a décidé de garder ses pions à les
droits garde le pion le pion g5
et il attaque la flambée des voix la
grotte pour défendre le plan b 2
donc alors qu'à l'instant
nous allons pouvoir parler avec nicolas
girard le maître international parisien
nicolas rebonjour rebond joueurs alors
une partie technique disait une partie
technique oui
avec peut-être un petit avantage alors
en ont ils semblent avoir je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas parce que j'ai déjà vu ce
genre de finale avec cavaliers
contrefout par exemple le cavalier c3
contre le fu e6 est en général le
cavalier prend le dessus c'est pas vous
c'est pas si facile que ça mais bon pour
l'instant la position est en tout cas
équilibré pour l'instant rien n'est
clair
sur cavaliers c4 le choix est à faire il
y à une menace directe dans cette
position la menace directe ces cavaliers
ces quatre ans à 3 et sur pions prend
cavaliers à 3 la tour c 8 prend le
cavalier en c3 et les noirs ont gagné un
pion oui c'est ce qui me faisait penser
que justement il avait un petit avantage
parce que c'est pas facile de parer
cette menace ben peut-être la solution
la plus simple c'est de prendre
de prendre le cavalier lecavalier oui cf
ça qui est intéressant aussi que se
passe-t-il après être cinq
il doit reculer le fou et puis ensuite
on jouerait fou pensée 4 quand même non
peut-être peut-être pas je sais pas il a
plus d espace michael adams son avantage
là ça c'est le gros avantage c'est ce
que j'explique et c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué c'est que son style est parfait
pour exploiter ce type davantage qui est
qui est apparemment microscopiques mais
mais mais qui n'est pas vraiment donc là
actuellement laurent il est plongé sur
l'échiquier ainsi son attitude et
laurent et plonger sur les chiffres clés
bientôt affalé et va mettre sa tête sur
les pièces noires
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur de
pencher trop la tête si on arrive à 6
ont franchi le milieu de l'échiquier
avec la tête on peut être oui pauvre un
blâme de larbitre oui parce qu'il ya des
joueurs comme ça qu'ils se penchent
tellement qui masque la vision du jeu
par là pour leurs adversaires et le
héros blanche par l'exemple
donc
voilà les noirs réfléchissent
donc voilà donc laurent
laurent pleine réflexion
donc laurent qui joue pour le club de
montpellier d'ailleurs un club qui est
chaque joueur évidemment chaque joueur
qui joue ici un club un club en première
division et montpellier est en tête du
championnat ex-aequo avec monaco
légèrement devant clichy et une autre
équipier mulhouse je crois mais donc
laurent frayssinet joujou pour le club
de montpellier il est en général 3 ou 4e
échiquier
avec mon équipe de drancy là on a joué
contre montpellier et il a il était au
troisième et chic et il a d'ailleurs
gagné contre man c'est un buteur
contre mon coéquipier godard
et laurent frayssinet donc en pleine
forme un grand connaisseur de la théorie
des ouvertures toutes les ouvertures à
la mode tous beaucoup de jeunes joueurs
il les connaît et sait tenaille dorff il
la connaît bien que là il semble en
difficulté ça fait déjà cinq bonnes
minutes jean louis qui réfléchit ce pas
mal de temps il n'a pas grand roque ça
l'ennuie il faut que tu fasses
absolument attention autant votre
position donc alors qu'est ce qui peut
faire sur cavaliers prend 1,3 à l'amst
puisque l'on maintenant on peut le faire
ce coup il y avait les points à 3 sur
cavaliers prend à 3 donc je pense que
l'intention d'adams dans cette position
et de jouer
safe sac
alors f5 f5 fou en 17 a priori fou en 17
et la faire sauter les cavaliers en
dessin ou modèle aux anneaux il ya
pioncer de non non je pense que c'est
dommage après l'idée l'idée l'idée sera
de jouer peut-être notre coup quoi non
mais je pense que la position n'est pas
la bonne n'ont cessé au blanc de
positions annoncée de laurent frayssinet
leurs offres au ciné et les allait me
faire grand roque
tu en es sûre
quasiment
j'ai un petit doute maintenant que oui
c'est bien freyssinet qui réfléchit
c'est bien freyssinet qui reste au noir
de jouer il ya une grande et blanc
d'accord la technique n'est pas
défaillante c
c'est ça non donc il joue pas qu'ils
avaient prend à 3 alors ça c'est quand
même assez ministre alors on va se
plonger
dans la position donc j'ai proposé le
coeff 5-fu 17
et peut-être f6 pour casser la structure
mais c'est vrai que je doute un petit
peu delà
de la force de cette variante
sinon
et voilà le plan est pris la réponse va
arriver
donc et adams ne répond pas
instantanément donc qu'il a eu il a
peut-être que m et ouais on la voit
d'ailleurs il a fait un hochement de
tête significatif il a peut-être commis
une erreur ce qui est tout à fait
possible même chez les joueurs de cette
force ils sont capables de faire des
fautes les plus les plus les plus plus
eryl si je puis dire puisque bon mais
réfléchissons un petit peu quand même il
faut faire attention maintenant c'est
une gaffe apparemment il l'a fait une
mini caractéristiques du joueur qui
regrette son dernier coup qui regrette
qui regrette regrette ok donc imaginons
par exemple un coup comme f 5 fu 17 et
tour des cats
l'idée de tourner quatre étangs de
dominer le cavalier en a trois c'est à
dire lui éviter une case de retrait
sekkat donc le forcer à venir sur la
case je vais mettre un petit peu les
trucs donc jouer f5 fou 17 et de jouer
par exemple tour des quatre pour pas que
lecavalier reviennent mais il peut jouer
bébé cinq ans peut jouer pions prom
plombé sa coalition qui ont b5 peut-être
mais dans cette dans ce cas de figure
en ce cas de figure il serait mieux
c'est vrai est sain alors voilà donc de
toutes façons
michael n'a peut-être pas le choix f5 et
un coup pour dominer les pièces et
essaie d'obtenir du contre jeu et
laurent a joué fou 17
donc donc les spectateurs avantage au
noir a priori un plan de plus m6 et
voilà donc les blancs
on sait pas encore si c'est du bluff ou
pas mais les blancs ils essayent
d'obtenir de casser cette structure par
exemple la menace est en effet prononcer
des cavaliers des cinq donc les blancs
déstabilise complètement
casse complètement cette structure de
pions puisqu'après les blancs les noirs
vont se retrouver avec un îlot de pions
un autre pur isoler et à notre île aux
deux pions alors pour obtenir cette case
centrale cet appui sur la case centrale
et obtenir la colonne f pour la tour et
la colonne t pour la tour donc voilà
obtenir du contre je je crois qu'il
vient de laisser éventuellement laurent
frayssinet remettre son fou il était en
russie ça me semble le bon coup sans
craindre bien on prend pions puisque le
roi noir peut reprendre tranquillement
cette tout à fait mais après faut aussi
quand même puis on prend 2,7 doit être
un bon coup plus que bon il faut prendre
ce pion sur fou aussi ce pur prononcé
trois prendre cette peut-être cavaliers
des cinq échecs
hanoi a le pion ces deux noms n'ont
sûrement pas ce coup sûrement pas ce
coup donc peut-être faut aussi c'était
un très très bon coup
je pense que lors on peut trouver ce
genre de coups il semble que michael et
arrive un peu tard aujourd'hui qu'il
n'est pas d'un record dans son assiette
et qu'il ait perdu un pion un petit peu
bêtement et que maintenant si laurent et
précis pendant les quelques coups qui
vont suivre il pourra conserver son
avantage mais à savoir que même avec
aplomb plus cette position est loin
d'être gagné bien sûr il ya le cavalier
noir il a capturé un pion mais en même
temps il un peu hors jeu actuellement il
est menacé d'être capturé à tout moment
ils les noirs doivent surveiller cette
possibilité alors ils ont un plan de
plus mais c'est peut-être les blancs qui
vont avoir les initiatives dans les
prochains coups alors vous aussi c'est
étonnant qu'ils le jouent pas au dessus
parce qu'on voit difficilement une autre
possibilité intéressante peut-être
cavaliers ccap tout simplement héros
mais lecavalier oui mais je pense que
quand on dire michael bénéficient de ce
que l'on peut l'appeler le seul qu'on
dira le
l' avantage de l'expérience c'est à dire
que comme michael a une expérience et un
joueur reconnu mondialement comme il
joue face un joueur un peu
inexpérimentée son adversaire se méfie
l'imaginent quelques fantômes dans la
position et ils jouent lentement il
prend du temps et là je pense que c'est
peut-être une erreur peut-être une
erreur quelque part comme quatre chefs
on l'a vu pendant la première demi
finale se donner un handicap autant
c'est gravissime et c'est souvent la
source d'erreurs importantes dans la fin
de la partie finalement la phase
décisive surtout que fout aussi c'est
quand même un coût très très con on dit
extrêmement classique puisqu'il contrôle
le centre il permet aux pièces de bien
communiquer je pense que ça doit être le
bon coup dans la position
donc fou au cices eyed peas peut-être
aussi à b5 éventuellement non
bessac oui mais tous ces couacs et si b5
menace b4 pas forcément puisque après b5
on peut jouer après bsb ça qu'on peut
jouer puis on prend 1,7 est sur b4 on
peut peut-être prendre en a trois et
et on a pris un pion et rien ne s'est
passé alors voilà il remet le fou mais
après une révolte trop longue voilà
exactement il a joué le coup qu'on avait
prévu mais
3 3 minutes plus tard et trois minutes
qui peuvent ils peuvent
faire la différence à la fin
alors pour madame ce comment essayer de
compenser le matériel perdu photo en
général trouver une attaque le joueur
d'échecs a perdu du matériel doit
trouver du dynamisme de l'espace quelque
chose pour compenser ça donc
comme coup plausible il ya là la brise
puis on prend pions qu'on a vus mais
d'un autre côté ça mais le roi sur une
bonne case en recettes et puis la
tourache 8 libéré également
donc ce serait peut-être pas une bonne
solution est-ce qu'il peut pas tout
simplement doublé commencé à doubler sur
la colonne des jouets tours en d2 ou en
d4 à nouveau ça obligerait les noir sans
doute
à replacer leurs cavaliers en c4 mais le
problème des noirs c'est quand même leur
tout en haut à droite qui a du mal à se
libérer un étant fermée encore pour un
bon moment la tourache suit évidemment
donc là dans cette position
pas évident de faire un choix avec les
blancs dans cette position puisque en
plus les blancs il faut signaler quand
même ont une faiblesse en h3 donc un
pion qui qui qui en prit qui est attaqué
par le fou donc la tour ne peut pas trop
facilement se déplacer
et
et en plus s'il vous je leur cavalier
ailleurs que sur la caf ainsi le pouls
de leurs cavaliers sur des sacs il y à
tour ses huit français deux échecs et
mat qui est une menace directe un joli
petit matin un joli petit matin oui qui
n'a pas de nom pas celui non pas celui
là
puisque évidemment aux échecs on donne
des noms au matin
donc voilà donc dans cette position
que va jouer peut-être ce qui peut en
cas d'attaqué de l'autre côté par h4
aussi à droite la hache 4 c'est à la
fois une attaque mais en même temps
c'est un coup positionnelle c'est à dire
qu'en jouant le coucou h3h cat la tour
pourra à nouveau être libérés et en plus
on menace h projet 5 avec un pion h6 qui
ne peut pas reprendre un vieux sac à
cause du clonage donc les noirs
répondrait gzg4 pop g5 g4 monsieur le
coup mais en même temps le pion angers 4
serait à nouveau affaiblie puisque le 2
pour l attaque et donc peut-être qu adam
est en train de calculer des comptes en
train de calculer les conséquences du
coup h4 ou peut-être deux pions prendre
73.7 et h4 parce que sur h4 il ya aussi
pions prend f6 qui est intéressant
laissant le bilan des six ans laissant
viande et 6 mai
comment dire mettant un accent un accent
aigu sur le développement oui c'est vrai
avec ensuite 3e set surtout reprendre et
6 donc on peut envisager h quatre pions
progressiste ou reprend des six est roi
le set avec un une position avec les
tours noir libérer les deux tours
toujours avantageuses pour les noirs
mais
peut-être pas suffisamment pour pour le
gain en tout cas leur adams en
difficulté parce que c'était pas prévu
de voir un homme en difficulté avec les
blancs adams en difficulté dès le départ
à cause d'une fête d'une faute d'une
faute infantile goal lire une faute que
même laurent n'aurait pas fait donc oui
comme quoi les joueurs les plus forts
peuvent peuvent laisser les choses les
plus les plus bêtes en souvent
donc dans cette position
mike elle réfléchit toujours d'ailleurs
jean tout à l'heure j'étais tellement
impressionné de voir michael faire une
fois de pareils que je pensais que qui
avait eu une erreur technique oui mais
une faute faute de transmission et
finalement non attention h4 je crois à
non couchés belle surprise foucher cat
donc exactement le même principe cash 4
c'est à dire michael est prêt par
exemple a échangé le pion à doubler son
pion mais parce que la tourache un
exercerait une pression très importante
sur la colonne h le pion h6 donc ce qui
est très important pour les auditeurs
c'est de constater que bon m'ont
confirmé premier réflexe dans la
position sont des réflexes d'ordre
disons positionnelle d'ordre je regarde
beaucoup la structure les mouvements et
tout ça est le jeu de pièces en plus
d'une certaine manière se fout aussi ce
contrôle la case du cavalier sur des
cinq donc il un peu gênant donc
actuellement je pense que adams mais
michael adams menace pas lui-même
d'échanger les fous puisque s'il fait
fou prend foussard mais un pinot noir en
plein centre très bien placé donc je
pense que peut-être il peut jouer là
laurent e rang et 6 tout simplement
pions prend pions pour monter son roi et
maître les tours en liaison c'est ça me
semble simple et peut-être après 36 donc
michael après pions problème 6 michael
pourrait jouer fou prend fou puis on
prend tout reprend puis on des six
attaques le pion ici c'est sûr roi des
champions en russe est doublé les tours
et le in oui le premier brasero
territoire ne peuvent pas échanger les
tours sur la huitième parce qu'après les
changes total des tours sur la huitième
en des huit lecavalier serait perdu
voilà donc la fille se serait pas bon le
cavalier pour l'instant n'est pas en
prison à 3 parce que sur fion prend à 3
la tour prend le cavalier mais si la
tour quitte cette colonne et prit
immédiatement
alors il reste pour les noirs peut être
à remettre le cavalier ou vers le centre
en c4 mais à ce moment là je vois pour
adam c'est une manoeuvre qui serait de
jouer car et les dessins immédiatement
ce qui serait assez forte
cavaliers des cinq ça va être la menace
après le départ du cavalier noir bien
sûr parce qu'actuellement il y aurait
maths mais si le cabinet noir bougies à
cavalier dessin qui est fort puisque le
fou noir peut pas prendre le cavalier au
centre car il est cloué exactement et je
pense que c'est l'idée principale
d'adams d'adams cette attaque il faut
voir que même avec du matériel en moins
adams est très très malin et en même
temps les défenses les meilleurs dans
une position soit aussi de défense
stratégique donc la défense stratégique
c'est évidemment dans certains dans
certains cas de figure de clouer se fout
de l'empêché pas de préparer cavaliers
des 5 et 6 le foot rend le cavalier le
fou prend la tour en ces 8 mais bon
actuellement le cavalier ne bouge pas de
c3 n'oublions pas oui oui il faut
d'abord que le cavalier noir retire son
ipod n'est plus ce math tour en français
deux tours prend ces deux sur cavani
dessin qui pendant ses deux
tours point c'est du joli petit moment
mais non
donc laurent qui réfléchit réfléchi
réfléchi
mais c'est vrai que dans cette position
il faut quand même plus réfléchir fou
aussi c'était vraiment le coup naturel
voilà il ajoute b 5 août les actifs
menace éventuellement b4
que
pour l'instant donc b5 et que va faire
michael peut-être que michael dans cette
position peut jouer un coup comme tour
h2 pour éventuellement de défendre le
plan c'est de les vendre le pion ces
deux donc tour h2 défendre le pion c2 et
éventuellement libérer ce cavalier c3
lui permettre d'aller sur la case des 5
et les noirs jouerait donc b4 quand même
b 4 cavaliers des cinq quand même
cavalier des cinq as we must le procès
serait pas bon d'accord donc b4 n'est
pas bon les noirs jouerait en revanche
cavaliers ces quatre des cinq baies 5
est à la fois intéressant mais à la fois
doute parce que b5 affaibli la structure
de pions c'est à dire que si la tour
prend le planter six le pion à 6 se
retrouve immédiatement prises donc quel
est
il faut il faut absolument compenser
cette secoue par des parts des solutions
tactiques
donc nous avons le plaisir de parler
aux malheureux perdants du premier match
vous l'a dit savent quatre chefs dont
vladislav bonjour
donc nous sommes en train d'analyser
cette partie il nous semble que michael
a fait une gaffe oui bon c'est à dire
que au début trouvé quelque part mais un
plus mais quand même après et
il a trouvé un super coup j'ai
exactement mais je pense que bo 5
n'était pas le meilleur répondre
je tour ses six pour protéger le pilote
des 6 et préparer le programme 6
la leçon la leçon qu'il faut tirer de
cette partie pour l'instant c'est une
leçon
oppositionnel c'est à dire la structure
est très importante et tous les coups
qui ont été jouées sont basés en
fonction des structures par exemple
comme j'ai expliqué forget 4
éventuellement s'il est fou s'échangent
le pion h est affaibli où exactement il
a en même temps ça évite d'avoir ce pion
faible le pion h3 et le pion b et le
groupe des sept dessins qui a faibli
quelque part la structure parce que le
pion à 6 peut être en prise donc tout ça
ce sont des notions positionnelle qu'il
ne faut qu'ils sont très importantes
dans ce type de parti qui est une partie
presque une finale quoi
finalement ça peut être
utilisée par tour des cadres avec l'idée
de doubler les tours ou à l'eau après
tout rage d'eau et donc à chaque fois
avec l'idée de
mobiliser les deux me mobiliser tous que
naît dans les prédispositions des bois
là tu voudrais juste demandé une
question donc je remarque que tu parle
très bien français vous recevrez donc
ah oui et puis on prend 1,7 quelle
surprise
michael
va directement à l'essentiel peut-être
qu'il envie tout simplement de jouer un
coup comme cavalier des 5 oui tout à
fait et un bon restaurant ses huit mois
ce que je critique c'est peut-être
cavaliers sedo dans cette position
cavalier pensait d'eux comme j'ai
compris c'est tu es sahel et des
initiales de jeu b52 laurent et laurent
est très tactique et donc probablement
cavaliers français 2 fait partie des de
son attirail de dans cette position de
coûts donc cavalier français de l'idc
qu'après roi prend ces deux le pion
avançant b4 et lecavalier ne peut pas
bouger parce qu'il est cloué oui à la
tour ans et 8 qui qui fait face au roi
en c2 voilà que c'est vrai que laurent
elle est toujours fidèle à son style est
hyper agressif moi je pense qu'un tel
combat des rois prendre cette île n'est
pas encore
tous rage 2 voilà donc
on arrive à être positionné normal quoi
normal avec la casse des 5 pour les
blancs et des petits affaiblissement
pour les noirs mais un pion plus oui
donc maintenant c'est exactement l'heure
de calculer précisément les lignes comme
cavalier ce 4e volet des synchros bouge
et puis
d'abord les questions seront les rois
bouge le roi le roi noir où il roman
noir après qu'avant les dessins que
cheikh donc est ce que chaque case assez
ces faiblesses dans le cavalier dessins
que le coût normal
et là que va faire laurent donc roi et
fuite peut-être rechute -
oui où ils auront
peut-être que ses proches du rock et
psychologiquement c'est le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer je ne sais pas où en est
le temps actuellement donc je pense
qu'ils doivent faire une petite salle
attenante au lido de titine à tous les
deux donc gros spectacle
donc voilà donc
au
f27 un développement normal
oui il faut il faut absolument besoin
d'autres de trouver quelque chose de
concret maintenant sinon ça va être de
moins de moins en moins bien que penses
tu de par exemple cavaliers des 5 et 6
pour éventuellement
attirer le roi dans une sorte de réseau
de maths peut-être avec les pièces au
bon réseau match
mais peut-être oui bon enfant c'est une
idée à korolev 6 o come all ye
oui
pour attirer le roi dans un coin sombre
maintenant peut-être roi h fruit doit
être jeu
tout retour tour pardon tour à tour à
5,8 pour donner un petit peu de cases au
roi puisque le roi on n'a pas beaucoup
oui sinon après core i5 un peu oublié
on peut commencer à oublier le gain de
la partie ou peut-être même le match nul
tout est possible bref
donc tour à chef 8 qui en plus a le
mérite de défendre un petit peu le pion
le pion le pion à vii donc voilà et
voilà où s est joué c'est jouer donc
laurent fascine et qui quand même dans
les moments difficiles arrivent quand
même à trouver coup assez rapidement ce
qui ce qui est tout à son honneur donc
ça devient de plus en plus intéressant
est maintenant de 3 est possible et avec
les deux prendre sur 10 b3 ou et donc
pour récupérer le pion mais non michael
veut plus il veut attirer le roi dans un
dans une situation embarrassante alors
là maintenant il a le choix il peut
peut-être répété la position mais où
peut-être c'est d'accentuer la pression
avec les avec les blancs il a un pion de
moins il a le choix il peut soit
continuer à attaquer soit répétée
donc que va-t-il faire
michael est très impressionnant parce
qu'il est très très très très calme ça
il se bos a comme d'hab mais quand même
je suis sûr qu'il va je bois trop en
mode et non
quelle surprise prend il échange tout
est beau et froid ah oui il affaiblit le
pion f qui est devenu puis on réussisse
et qui devait nous fait plus faible
qu'avant donc ce genre de partie fait
penser à des parties de deux vieux loup
de mer quoi disons c'est à dire une
partie avec une ouverture bompas très
très intéressante assez solide qui s'est
transformée en une position à long terme
disons où les joueurs font un bras de
fer les bhl il doit regagner pions il
met la pression et après finalement
la tension augmente et on arrive dans
une finale de plus en plus tendue avec
un manque de temps et tout quoi donc
c'est vraiment critique
oui robot 2 et maintenant 24 doit être
joué avec les dés de constituer un
réseau du moins comme les d1 comme les
c3 donc il reste quatre minutes alors on
avec les noirs et sept minutes à michael
actuellement donc michael ait mis autant
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire maintenant
contre la menace cavaliers des ans
ces sinistres cette menace spectateurs
c4 doit être joué maintenant c4 est le
seul coup c'est car je vois pas l'autre
c4 est le seul coup et peut-être que la
position s'oriente vers une partie à peu
près équilibré donc
après ces quatre à
tout reprendre et non le juan revient
sur ses seins sur cavaliers sur
cavaliers d un échec le roi bien sûr
c'est en est sûre cavaliers c3 l'europe
est en d2 et il n'est pas m'as tu on ne
peut pas maté le roi puisque le roi fui
par la case de
3com michael est malin il laisse il
laisse à son adversaire qui est très
tactique la possibilité de créer un math
et lors on le voit tout de suite mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas m'as tu
sais c'est un piège c'est un piège je
pense mais quand même rêve de cavale
était un cavalier 3 il me semble que ce
doit être pour formulations
tour de donc lors on n'a plus beaucoup
de temps et il a il place il plaçait il
a perdu beaucoup de points maintenant
que vous allez aussi ce que valait 200
cas
oui oui ça c'est le problème c'est le
problème me faut
c'est dommage c'est dommage qu'ils aient
qui des perdu ce pion michael sort ce
roi
personnellement je crois que ça se passe
pas très bien pour le jeune espoir
français qu'il a il a très bien débuté
il a eu un très bon départ dans cette
partie il était vraiment très très
brillant mais malheureusement
actuellement il est en train de perdre
un petit peu le fil de la partie ouais
donc c'est vrai que bo 5 dieu être jeu
avec les décors et les ados ou de
développer un jeu wii structurellement
le coupé cinq étaient affaiblissant donc
voilà donc maintenant ça devient de plus
en plus désespérant
c'est désespérant
ouais
donc voilà je sais j'ai entendu parler
que de ton match donc dans quelques
jours contre le numéro un hollandais
piquette oui exactement on va commencer
ce match et le disent et du le dise cet
axe et se déroulera à cannes ces rageux
dans le tels que martinez à l'hôtel
martinez
certains matchs de huit partis d'autres
partis avec eux la cadence normale donc
voilà donc roi des ans les blancs
sorte le roi donc dû la nuit même des
petits problèmes techniques mais c'est
vrai que maintenant c'est techniquement
gagner
techniquement gagnons un rouage deux
doigts d'y rejouer
entourage 2e tour 11 mois tournage de we
parce que surtout reprend 1,4 il y avait
tout simplement cavaliers f5 à vih 5 et
6 avec une fourchette fatale
donc voilà la partie la partie est très
tendue la tour h2 attaque le pion h3
donc michael a appuyé ont eu pas ses
cavaliers f6 le roi est presque matteo 5
avec l'idée aussi ses tours fc est mat
que va faire laurent
laurent est en difficulté bizarrement ce
sont les bois maintenant qui lie matin
bon il faut donner les chais que trois
courses et peut-être tour à tour hebdo
pour six tours de roues de suite même
impossible 3 e 1 et et j'espère que nous
l'aurons on va peut-être pas mais il ya
un piège quand même c'est qu'après tour
3e 6 lui fait aux riches accroît prend
et touré chaque ici et tout reprend
cavaliers
c'est le petit piège pour éviter de
perdre une pièce mais il a toujours
appuyé en moins oui quand même mais il a
vu ça je pense
laurent on va être un petit peu déçu
après cette partie parce qu'il a eu une
bonne ouverture et
et il a craqué
donc voilà
tour f4 n'est pas encore fait c'est pas
encore fait mais
il faut encore attendre un petit peu de
jeu quand les âges sans que tour bouge
6e avec les 2 et 3 8
au jeu oui exactement exactement l'idée
c'est que la tour ne peut pas quitter la
colonne f rouh eux deux a encore plus
cavalier h2 donc là le cavalier est ce
qu'on appelle aux fraises c'est à dire
le cavier est complètement sur la bande
il ne peut plus jouer dans la partie
donc
le pion à vence et la menace est tout
simplement e6 e7 leroy bougeant ici
cavaliers échec 3 bougeant à vii et
dames donc laurent abandonne fort
logiquement
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc voilà la première partie de
la demi finale a vu la victoire de
michael adams
suite une partie extrêmement compliqué
donc peut-être je vais demander un petit
mot aux deux joueurs
michael bublé tower d'abord tu vises
game
cycle est
d'accord donc à leurs commentaires
techniques pour le moins puisque
apparemment michael pense qu'après
cavalli prend 1,3 les noirs étaient
mieux il a eu peur de contre jeu à base
de tout reprend ses droits le sacrifice
de qualité mais enfin donc il a eu chaud
de trouver du contre jeu dans cette
partie alors maintenant je demande un
petit mot à laurent frayssinet
non mais moi je suis assez d'accord je
pense que j'étais j'étais mieux mais
disons que j'ai c'est trop de contre jeu
quand il a fait comme s'il a commencé à
faire cavalier 6 je sentais j'avais plus
trop de temps j'ai senti le contre jeu
et après il a et il a bien joué donc je
suis fait c'était j'ai raté ma chance
oui et pour la prochaine partie donc une
deuxième deuxième partie dans sa
demi-finale tu vas être obligé de
l'emporter avec les blancs laurent une
stratégie spéciale où tu préfères pas en
dire plus
essayer de jouer non mais bon je vais
essayer de faire de mon mieux mais
disons que voilà
bombe espérons qu'il fera de son mieux
en tout cas donc on va remercier les
deux joueurs donc merci pour cette
première partie maintenant je vais
appeler notre ami commentateurs que vous
avez eue pour les commentaires de cette
partie jean-luc chavanon on va faire un
petit bilan de cette partie ensemble et
ensuite on vous laissera vous reposer
quelques minutes avant la prochaine
partie
donc jean luc si tu peux venir qu'on
voit un peu qu'on voit la tête qu'on met
une tête en fait sur les commentaires
qu'on entend via ce système triton
donc je vais le présenter un petit peu
il s'agit du maître international qui
joue pour le club de cannes
il est donc il fait partie des tous
meilleurs joueurs français il a été dans
les meilleurs espoirs juniors enfin dans
les mondiaux il a été dans le top 20
junior mondial jean-luc chavanon alors
bonsoir jean luc bonsoir eloi cette
partie tu penses que laurent frayssinet
aurait pu bénéficier de d'un avantage
certain et l'emporter ou michael a
trouvé du contre jeu au bon moment je
pense qu'il a quand même obtenu un bon
avantage après cavaliers prend à 3 ce
qui s'est passé c'est que c'est que la
position était quand même délicate mais
elle était mieux et au bout d'un moment
après avoir joué sept dessins qu'il a
perdu un petit peu le fil de la position
et le temps aidant il a fini par
vraiment être très très mal
voyez effectivement la pendule n'a pas
marché dans cette partie c'est
exceptionnel ça va être réparée pour la
prochaine partie on donc on n'a pas pu
suivre les temps en direct donc laurent
frayssinet témoin bien moins bien la
pendule c'est suite à cette crise de
temps on est obligé de jouer des coups
qu'il a fait les erreurs et qu'il n'a
pas su profiter de son avantage comment
tu vois la deuxième partie du match la
deuxième partie du match je pense que il
est possible que les joueurs s'oriente à
peu près dans le même type de position
c'est-à-dire des positions très très
solide avec une finale très tendu parce
que même si laurent est jeune c'est un
joueur qui aime bien ce genre de
position son répertoire le le permet
mais en même temps il est plein
d'astuces en asie qui l'a hissé de
tenter un matin en baie ans quand il a
joué quand il a mis sa tour sur la
huitième il a voulu mater le roi donc il
y aura plein de petites tactiques aussi
quoi donc là en tout cas on souhaite les
meilleures chances à laurent pour pour
le suspense de cette demi-finale en cas
d'égalité il y aura des bides se
départagent puis ensuite des partis cinq
contre quatre minutes en cas de nouvelle
égalité en fin de ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que ça va pas être facile puisque
michael adams et numéro 7 mondial donc
on vous donne rendez vous dans dix
petites minutes donc merci jean luc on
va de nouveau suivre tes commentaires
pour la prochaine partie et je vous
invite à aller à sortir un petit peu de
mercy
belga
donc les joueurs ont une petite pause
donc nous reprenons un petit peu nos
commentaires donc le match va bientôt
démarrer et donc michael a gagné la
première partie avec les avec les blancs
donc la revanche va être terrible
laurent va se
faire son maximum peut-être que mon
commentaire a été un petit peu fou tout
à l'heure devant le public parce que
finalement je me rends compte que
laurent a peut-être rien à perdre et
qu'il est prêt à attaquer sauvagement
bon malheureusement son répertoire est
actuellement donné par répertoire
d'attaquants sur 4,5 il vous l'avez en
décharge l'espagnol mais il a très très
confiance dans ses connaissances
théoriques donc on verra ce que ça donne
sinon j'espère que personne entend ce
que je dis là dans la salle je veux pas
donner un indice à un michael et
donc nous sommes donc en direct du
théâtre fémina donc
donc le tournoi le trophée clc organisé
donc à bordeaux et est sponsorisée donc
par l'assurance clc par france info par
diagonale par là par sud ouest par l'edf
par le club d'échecs aspom et donc les
joueurs le vainqueur pourra gagner un
super trophée
les joueurs donc
joue dans une salle superbe enfin on
dire construite en 1921
les différents qu'on dira
la salle on dirait l'équipement donc est
fait par donc marcel abad qui s'est
occupé donc des chaises et du système
triton avec son ami ingénieur du scion
luc escande donc le système triton je
vais bien répéter aux aux auditeurs est
un système qui permet de créer un mur
virtuel c'est à dire que la scène est
complètement isolée de de la
2d
de la salle de la salle du théâtre donc
les spectateurs peuvent entendre les
commentaires que je donne dans la cabine
et 2
sans que les joueurs seront entendus
quoi que ce soit donc voila et sinon
sinon donc la musique lui la musique du
générique du tournoi et du générique de
l'émission de diagonale et composé par
régis fogel end of the line qui va
bientôt sortir un album et dieu créa la
femme donc son premier album aux
éditions danaé systema c'est un chanteur
français très connu qui va bientôt faire
son premier grand concert à paris le 20
mai donc bonne chance pour régis
voilà donc tout ça a été dit d'ailleurs
je tiens juste à signaler qu'on peut
trouver sur internet en format mp3 /
france mp3 point com
les cds de régis une chose très
importante voilà donc sinon je tiens
aussi à remercier un ami à moi
qui nous a pas mal aidé puisque
lui nous a un petit peu aidé donc
antoine lac et je te dis coucou voilà
qui est qui travaille pour le journal de
chez vous à la rochelle et et puis voilà
quoi donc sinon donc la partie va
recommencer jouer laurent frayssinet va
avoir les blancs donc laurent frayssinet
vice championne du monde juniors contre
michael adams
2713 je crois tête de série numéro 9 ou
10 au monde un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde plusieurs fois demi finaliste du
championnat du monde un joueur vraiment
très très fort qui va va défendre avec
les noirs qui a un style très sobre très
efficaces et ils auront donc un jeune
talent aura vraiment forte à faire c'est
vrai qu'il est quand même qu'ils jouent
contre l'adversaire le mieux classé du
tournoi donc il n'a pas un rôle très
facile mais je pense que je pense qu il
il va nous faire il va nous il va créer
quelques surprises en tout cas je
l'espère donc michael adams 2715 contre
laurent frayssinet 2501 mais beaucoup
beaucoup de talent donc
donc je signale aussi à nos chers
auditeurs qu'il est possible
actuellement de deux sauts de dalles de
d'ouvrir la cellule de chat en direct
donc vous pouvez ouvrir le chat et poser
vos questions à sébastien silva et et
pour une transmission voilà donc
accessible sur le site de canal web
www.canwea.ca est voilà c'est à peu près
tout donc la partie va bientôt commencer
les joueurs les joueurs en scène donc
voilà et voilà donc
je suis toujours en cabinet à mon ami
nicolas qui va me rejoindre
non il est parti d'iran jura joëlle donc
c'est très intéressant donc vous avez vu
quand même le comportement très très
fair play de de vladislav quatre chefs
qui après avoir perdu contre contre joël
son match est venu dans la cabine très
gentiment de commentaires et a fait
quelques commentaires très intéressant
sur la partie
2-2 sur la partie donc de laurent
frayssinet contre michael adams voilà
donc voilà
donc une édition une quatrième édition
de ce tournoi donc finalement créé par
notre ami stéphane laborde
qui a eu l'idée de
de ce rendez-vous comment dire
spectacle des échecs et qui aussi est le
créateur de cette émission de télé
diagonale qui
visibles toutes les semaines en direct
de de
[Musique]
20h30 jusqu'à 20 du de 20h jusqu'à 10
vingt-et-une 21h jusqu'à 10 jusqu'à 22
heures tous les vendredis
d'ailleurs pendant l'émission il est
également possible d'aller sur le tchat
que j'anime régulièrement donc encore
sur le site de canal web à www point met
donc et vous pouvez aussi aller sur les
leçons vous pouvez prendre des leçons
des leçons multi niveaux des leçons
comment dire des leçons pour débutants
ou des leçons pour joueur de club donc
toujours sur le site de diagonale donc
voilà donc ce tout est dit donc mon cher
nicolas tes impressions sur cette partie
alors là je reviens au premier match
entre lautier et
quatre chefs parce que j'ai eu une
information c'est que quatre chefs deux
fois à quitter la scène pendant la
partie je l'avais pas remarqué quelqu'un
m'a dit ça et j'ai eu la confirmation de
joël lautier qui était un peu à peu
choqué par le fait que son adversaire se
permettre de se lever et partir comme si
vous voulez prendre l'ascendant
psychologique sur lui en disant moi moi
tu vois je suis capable de m'en aller
pendant la partie perdre trois minutes
en partant peut-être qu'il a été aux
toilettes tout simplement peut-être mais
enfin d'après joëlle moment c'était
uniquement un truc psychologiquement
l'impressionner et oui les matchs aux
échecs sont des grands débats des grands
fight psychologique et et en même temps
technique parce que tout se passe quand
même sur l'échiquier comme on l'a vu
dans la partie précédente donc une
grande déception quand même de voir
laurent perdre cette partie qui lui
semblait pas forcément acquise mais où
au moins le partage du point on était
vraiment très très méritée oui oui il
avait obtenu une très bonne position
mais s'est pas méfié du fighting spirit
anglais c'est à dire que l'anglais qui
sent qu'il est en mauvaise posture
devient espèce de réflexe également oui
du flegme et enfin surtout du fait ici
paris c'est à dire que quand ça va mal
un anglais va
sortir les dents et va trouver
l'impossible faire
c'est le sprint à l'anglais c'est à dire
qu'il est capable de
de se sortir les tripes pour trouver ce
fou g4 par exemple f5 f6 quand il est en
difficulté adams comme tous les joueurs
anglais trouvent des ressources
extraordinaires se démoralise jamais et
contre attaque et là on a vu finalement
et avec un plan de moins et bien il a
complètement retourné la situation et il
a obtenu contre attaque gagnant win
michael qui a une expérience fantastique
il a joué contre les meilleurs joueurs
de la planète dans d énormément de
tournois il a été habitué à défendre
face à des joueurs comme garry kasparov
et anatoli karpov vladimir kramnik il a
même battu kramnik l'année dernière dans
le cycle du championnat du monde à las
vegas donc il est capable de battre les
meilleurs ont les meilleurs meilleurs
joueurs de la planète alors donc
donc il est capable de se sortir de
mauvaise situation évidemment surtout
dans ses systèmes élimination directe je
les ai vus par exemple en 97 à groningue
c'était là le championnat du monde
élimination directe le premier organisé
par elengy nov et oui là il est allé
jusqu'en finale des candidats il a perdu
contre un hand à l'ultime blitz de
départage c'est vraiment il n'arrivait
pas à se départager ils ont fait je sais
pas 12 14 parties je m'en rappelle plus
le nombre exact et c'est vraiment à la
dernière dernière limite que 1 an 2
s'est qualifié pour jouer contre kharkov
en finale à lausanne l'année d'après oui
deux fois en demi-finale en demi-finale
aussi à las vegas donc c'est un joueur
vraiment très talentueux et très très
comment dire très bagarreur très
accrocheur qui n'a pas s'il vraiment
très comment dire
pétaradant il n'est pas là en train de
faire des sacrifices et tout mais il est
très efficace très efficace et c'est sa
sobriété qui le qui font son succès
d'ailleurs
vlad était très admiratif du coup j'ai 4
qui était un coup très très subtil on a
on avait les prémices d'une idée allait
droit dans la salle banalisons penser à
h4 pour essayer de créer quelque chose
mais fou g4 était vraiment le coup la
surprise le plus direct puisqu'il a lié
à la fois la taille du pion h6 donc sur
la colonne h et en même temps le
contrôle de la casse des 5 il était à un
coup qui avait deux utilités et c'était
quelque chose d'assez remarquable de de
sa part en fait il a cédé un pion à
trois là pour laisser les noirs avec un
cavalier plus ou moins acrobatique sur
cette case
et pendant ce temps-là organiser
lui-même une offensive il faut noter
aussi que la tour en haut à droite de
laurent frayssinet h8 été immobilisé
pendant quasiment tout
le début de la partie ce qui lui a coûté
la partie de ce qu'il est resté trop
passif il avait son plus en plus laurent
frayssinet mais aucune menace et toutes
les mauvaises sont vu de la part des
bleus a ensuite oui exactement même si
la position est pas très bonne après
cavaliers prend à 3 pour les blancs ce
type de position je pense que adams a
souvent l'occasion de rencontrer ce type
de position difficile est de trouver des
ressources et finalement
ces dépositions où il faut vraiment être
très précis pour pour arriver à gagner
avec les blancs avec avec les noirs et
et les fautes comment dire les chances
peuvent se balancer très facilement et
je pense que michael l'a bien démontré
dans cette partie alors ça va être
intéressant dans la deuxième ce qui va
se produire je pense laurent frayssinet
va jouer aux quatre lui aussi s'est
amené comme mc du pion du roi et pour
adams alors est-ce qu'il va jouer la
solidité avec par exemple la défense
karo kann qu'ils emploient souvent ou la
défense petrov là l'asymétrie e45 kf3
4,6 il peut également jouer aussi e45
cavalière trois cavaliers c6
auquel cas les joueurs vont probablement
joué une variante des changes de
l'espagnol donc soyez c'est la
spécialité avec les blancs de l'offre
c'est la spécialité de laurent fois ci
n'est donc c'est un petit peu ce que
j'ai commenté tout à l'heure mais pour
laurent c'est vrai qu'actuellement il
est très confiant et tout comme il est
jeune et où il croise dans ses variantes
mais peut-être que dans ce cas de figure
il aurait peut-être recours à des
variantes un petit peu marginale je
pense par exemple à la thrombose ski
parce que laurent est capable de jouer
ce genre de système il le pourrait
éventuellement essayer de déstabiliser
mais rappelons que michael adams est un
spécialiste de la troupe offs qui alors
la thrombose ski c'est un nom un petit
peu barbare pour les pour les novices
mais la troupe ski c'est une ouverture
qui existent que l'on peut obtenir après
des quatre cavaliers f6 fou g5 donc
c'est une ouverture qui qui est très
très comment dire qu'on va décrire un
petit peu chaotique je dirais un peu
chaotique et surtout elle sort de la
théorie de ce deuxième coup pratiquement
il ya assez peu de l'analyse
sur cette ouverture finalement donc on
verra on verra michael de toute façon je
suis heureux quatre jours à c6 et e5
je ne pense pas qu'il jouera une
ouverture comme la pire qu'ils jouaient
à de temps en temps mais qu'ils
utilisent probablement pour le combat je
pense que michael va est resté fidèle à
son style sobre prêt à jouer longtemps
parce qu'il est là pour se battre mais
dans son style quoi donc jouer des
parties longues un peu fond de court
comme j'ai décrit tout à l'heure où au
finalement
tout se fait un petit peu à l'usure par
des finesses part des choses un petit
peu un film mais qui s'accumulent qui
finalement au bon tout à l'heure on
construit une victoire oui arrive
toujours dans le style de michael aime
se trouve c'est ce qu'on peut remarquer
c'est toujours des regroupements de ses
forces en milieu de partie il est
toujours finalement assez compact dans
son ces pièces sont jamais trop dispersé
ça a été assez laide d'ailleurs dans
celle là où il a laissé prendre un pion
sur le côté à a3 il laisse le côté
gauche au noir puis lui il accumule des
forces au centre et finalement il a
réussi à placer son cavalier des cinq
sont et à percer et finalement au centre
est un peu à la lan d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est le joueur au top niveau qui a
le placement de pièces le plus sobre
plus efficace qui ne qui n'a jamais une
pièce vraiment très mal placé qui arrive
toujours être très bien organisés et
face auxquels pour gagner il faut quand
même faire preuve de génie ou de quelque
chose d'un petit peu exceptionnel il est
capable de battre finalement comment
dire un peu comme une machine il est
capable de se programmer pour battre la
plupart des joueurs et que le lait peu
de joueurs qui au monde qui sont
capables de le battre sont des joueurs
qui emploient des systèmes vraiment hors
du commun des comme gary par exemple ou
qui ont une grosse grosse préparation et
et qui sont prêts à le lui qui le peut
être le surprenne ou qui ont une
préparation telle que qui n'arrive pas à
voir la défense adéquate et puis alors
ce qui est aussi caractéristique chez
adam c'est la régularité dans ses
résultats il est 7e mondial et il joue
quasiment à chaque tournoi à ce niveau
là jamais de grandes variations que ce
soit négative ou positive il est
toujours les résultats d'un des
résultats très régulier avec peu de
défaites que de victoires aussi mais
toujours un jeu très solide et puis
capable d'inquiéter kasparov on l'a vu
au dernier tournoi devait icahn t il
avait un pion de plus contre kasparov
qui a trouvé des coûts miraculeux pour
faire nul
michael est un chasseur de primes il est
toujours là dans les grands rendez-vous
dans les gros budget finalement aussi il
est toujours là il sait jouer il sait se
motiver icc il a toujours comment dire
il est toujours très motivé mais en même
temps c'est un jour très sympathique oui
qui est capable qui a beaucoup qui est
très très populaire d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je tiens ça de source sûre
que
michael adams est le joueur le plus
populaire en russie plus populaire que
tous les joueurs c'est le joueur le plus
populaire chez les joueurs russes c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup surpris
et kiné mais il est très modeste et il
est très
très humble très humble et très
décontracté tous et il se pose pas de
questions il a il donne l'impression
d'être quelqu'un de simple et en plus en
plus en même temps il a quand même un
jeu très très très intelligent c'est un
joueur très doué mais surtout il disait
tout à l'heure il fait sa cuisine série
s'intéresse pas vraiment à la théorie
générale
qui se trouvent dans les informateurs ou
dans les bouquins les plus sérieux lui
on a l'impression qu'ils ne fait
confiance qu'à lui même il joue son jeu
sans trop se préoccuper de deux des
modes c'est peut-être ce qui a fait ça
ce qu'on dira son évolution puisque je
me souviens que début des années 90 il
était il était parmi les meilleurs
joueurs au monde déjà mais ces résultats
étaient moins impressionnants et
peut-être que petit à petit à force de
créer son propre système il a fini par
bien le maîtriser et être capable
maintenant de l'imposer à beaucoup de
joueurs ouais c'est ça oui il arrive à
se trouver toujours sur son terrain en
fait des positions assez calme et où il
n'a pas de faiblesse où ils jouent
groupés comme je disais avec des
résultats très régulier parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à le déstabiliser donc
revenons à laurent frayssinet donc
laurent frayssinet est un joueur qui a
été vice champion du monde junior qui
est capable donc du meilleur qui aime
finalement les tactiques qui est quand
même quelqu'un d'assez malins qui est
capable de trouver beaucoup de pièges
donc finalement moi je pense qu'il doit
garder les pièces parce que là il a
tendu une tactique avec une tour et un
cavalier il a essayé de faire un match
mais le match a été très facile à part
et je pense que michael avait même vu
pas mal de temps à l'avance et
c'est pas suffisant on mate pas avec
deux pièces comme ça quoi c'est vraiment
pas facile il faudrait qu'il ait
beaucoup plus de pièces et des
possibilités attaque sur le roc de
michael par exemple ah oui dans les
complications tactique freyssinet et
redoutable alors évidemment d'autant
plus qu'il a perdu la première partie il
a intérêt à garder dame sur l'échiquier
et puis et puis à jouer l attaque avec
les blancs là il n'a rien à perdre donc
j'espère qu'on aura une partie dynamique
donc voilà donc pour l'instant un petit
avantage à michael donc même un gros
avantage mais la revanche laurent hallé
blanc donc on peut toujours y croire et
en plus c'est bon il est très sympa
aussi on a parlé de michael mais bon
laurent frayssinet est un jeune joueur
très très sympathique qui qui qui déjà
s'est installé comme un professionnel
actif enfin pas professionnel mais comme
un joueur de très très fort niveau d'un
niveau professionnel actif chez les
joueurs français il participait déjà à
plusieurs jeux en france il a failli
d'ailleurs je crois sortir etienne
bacrot cette année au championnat de
france 2 2
de besançon absolument il était dans le
départage en blitz là il avait un pion
plus non une il avait dans le blitz
décisif il avait et c'était nul il
suffisait de faire nul et se qualifier
et puis il ya eu des répétitions coup
vraiment il y avait rien à faire c'était
complètement bloquée et il a perdu une
pierre et il a laissé un cavalier
emprise comment
c'était horrible et son tournoi était
finie et il n'a pu se qualifier pour la
finale et la gagner gagner facilement
donc
voilà la partie comment soir pour cette
dernière partie de soirée donc on a eu
quelques problèmes techniques comme vous
avez pu le voir dans la la phase la
partie précédente la pendule n'avait pas
marché nokla nous avons pris des mesures
pour être capable de vous dire
exactement combien de temps il reste et
comme ça on n'aura plus le souci de
savoir si un joueur est proche de la
défaite par la pendule ou s'il est
tranquille et qu'il lui reste encore
largement le temps de finir la partie
donc maintenant nous allons pouvoir
commencer tout est en ordre je vous prie
de nous excuser pour ce petit ce léger
retard je vais donc appeler nos deux
joueurs laurent frayssinet michael adams
[Applaudissements]
voilà je vais laisser la parole à
monsieur l'arbitré pour lancer cette
partie
bien très bien alors donc c'est même
punition donc deux parties de une partie
par dans deuxième manche de 25 minutes
par joueur je vais la prendre je la
prendrai quitte
donc les joueurs vont bientôt commencer
la lumière
s'éteint sur la scène
ils auront commencé énergiquement avec
son coup préféré e 4 e cat 5 cavaliers
f3 donc cette variante des changes de
l'espagnol arrive à grands pas à 6
france et 6 et win avait n'hésite pas
pourtant ça une rep les voilà en de
nullité exactement c'est ce que j'avais
prévu tout à l'heure quand j'ai quand
j'étais sur un coup surprenant d'amstar
évoluer ça c'est une surprise et
d'ailleurs laurent frayssinet s'arrête
ce coup dame en f 6 il n'a pas vu
souvent c'est une préparation je pense
que michael a préparé cette ce coup
assez peu joué et en même temps
finalement c'est un petit cadeau qui
rend à laurent puisque il joue une
position qui va être très compliqué très
très compliqué après des 4 et le coup
logique pions prend des 4 par exemple et
là que va faire laurent donc que va
faire laurent dans cette position peut
pousser un e 5 qui peut pousser en cinq
noms ils jouent ou g5 donc là pour
l'instant tout est très connue foulée
cinq dames des six donc une petite
nuance la position exacte existe aussi
avec avec la dame en d6 donc
les blancs sont mieux développer mais
sera demandée si je pense que les blancs
ne n'ouvre pas tout de suite il joue
plutôt ces trois des quatre sur la
demande et si ce donc
que va-t-il se passer dans cette
position donc le leur on réfléchit
peut-être peut encore gagner des temps
sur la dame je vais un poussant le pion
ou alors il peut aussi c'est normalement
l'esprit de ce cette ouverture c'est
d'échanger les dames aussi avec les
blancs puisque les noirs en dépit ont
doublé les blancs peuvent jouer dame
prend pions estimant que la fin de
partie résultant de les changer d'âme
leur est favorable et non il préfère
jouer sur l' avantage de mobilisation
des blancs car le roi noir est encore à
deux coups du rock et la dame noire
aussi peu est attaqué il peut y avoir
des coups
qui attaquent la dame noire qui
permettent des combinaisons peut-être
déjà ici est-ce qui peut envisager des
attaques du style e51 sacrifice de pions
et sur dame prend 1,5 jouer f4 lors de
va rien je ne pense pas je prends soin
mais bon pourquoi pas dans cette
position peut-être qu'il faut il faut
peut-être ramener le four en a il prend
sept cavaliers prendre le set ça c'est
étonnant parce que il favorise l'arrivée
du petit rock des noirs et il semble que
les noirs s'en sortent facilement après
cet échange de tir où il a peut-être
même grand roque pourquoi pas aussi
pourra pas sortir le fou ces 8es grand
roque et puisque finalement le roi
allèles dame ne sera pas trop trop en
danger quoi donc je ne sais pas le fou
sortir voilà fou 17 peut-être grand
roque peut-être grand aucune partie à
recomposer donc les blancs dans cette
position on une honte une majorité de
pions évidemment allèles roi avec eux 4
f de g 2 h 2 contre 3 petits pions noirs
et donc ils vont probablement profiter
de ça on prépare en effet 4 e 5 plus
tard mais les noirs auront quand même un
roi peut-être aller droit très très bien
établie la possibilité de contrer sur
cette structure en poussant un peu les
pions noirs donc je pense que la case
idéal pour le roi est plutôt à l'el dame
je pense pour le roi noir dans cette
position vous donner le dernier coup
l'indiquent puisqu'il a sorti le fouet
en 17 s'est visiblement pour faire le
grand orgue oui donc là laurent va
réfléchir
il faut qu'il a il faut qu'il amène ses
pièces il faut qu'il amène ses pièces
dans le à l'attaqué et actuellement il
ne peut pas déplacer ces pièces trop
facilement puisque le cavalier des
quatre n'est pas clouer mais disons que
la dame ne peut pas aller en f3 pour
jouer autour des 1 à cause de dame prend
cavaliers des quatre tout simplement
donc actuellement il faut faire
attention alors que va faire laurent il
peut proposer un échange de dames mais
je ne sais pas si c'est le moment
le moment parfait pour le pro pour le
faire il peu près aussi allongé
sacrifice d'options 5 mais non cavaliers
b3 donc laurent accepte la fin de partie
éventuellement accepte la fin de partie
éventuellement alors est ce que michael
veut échanger les dames il le fait il le
fait sans réfléchir donc tour à prendre
et un probablement cette position je
pense que c'est la bonne tour voilà
c'est ce qui a été fait il manque une
tour il faudrait donc qu'il n'a pas dû
la placer au centre de la case oui qui
replace la tour en d1
donc petit l'arbitré intervienne mais
n'a pas vu non plus et donc l'arbitré
n'a pas vu la tourment 41 il ya une tour
ici sur cette case une tour blanche qui
venir de cette case là voilà donc les
noirs réfléchissent oui car le cavalier
blanc b3 envie de sauter sur la casse
ces cinq alors c'est ça que adams
probablement adams va peut-être jeu b6
alors d'abord ou à mais alors les coûts
noir ne passe plus sur l'échiquier
il faut il faut réparer les problèmes
techniques absolument
donc puisque michael a répondu à laurent
qu'on ne voit pas le coup et qu'on ne
voit pas le coup effectué larbitre doit
intervenir ou les techniciens donc tour
à des 1
je sais pas si b6 grand roque je crois
qu'il a joués b6 mme probablement b6
pour éviter cavaliers c'est simple
on va voir si c'est laurent frayssinet
qui joue ça veut dire que le coût de
michael adams n'est pas passée sur
l'échiquier
alors là c'est très ennuyeux
car il faudrait interrompre la partie
pour régler le problème sinon personne
ne peut suivre donc
une petite confidence je ne suis pas le
coach de laurent mais je lui ai donné
quelques quelques confidences sur son
choix psychologique et je lui avais dit
de faire très attention à ne pas jouer
les variantes qu'il a l'habitude de
jouer ou de vraiment et je sais pas s'il
a fait le bon choix dans cette partie
revanche je n'en suis pas sur mais bon
ils avaient vraiment envie de jouer
cette variante échange de l'espagnol
donc on verra bien
je sais pas ce que tu en penses nicolas
mais a priori canton il faut gagner une
partie pour rétablir les équilibres au
score on choisit pas enfin si c'est
vraiment confiance en elle il la joue et
puis j'ai fait du mans contre bacrot par
exemple il l'avait joué il était
avec à chaque fois des meilleures
positions mais exactement où il est
quand michael adams c'est qu'il va jouer
le grand poète bordeaux déjà depuis
quinze jours
laurent frayssinet il a dû regarder et
puis bah ouais c'est ça la part qu'il ne
fonctionne plus la partie doit être
établi actuellement donc autrement
michael a joué cette vente des changes
de l'espagnol contre les meilleurs
joueurs de la planète il a eu beaucoup
de problèmes à plusieurs reprises il a
même perdu une partie très très connue
contre alexei shirov je ne sais plus à
quel tour noire et dans une finale
technique où il a fini par gaffé mais
bon alexei shirov quand même qui le
numéro 3 ou 4 mondial quoi donc
il a il a préparé cette vente contre les
meilleurs joueurs de la planète s'est
s'était même son point faible je veux
dire donc
raison de plus pour faut faire très
attention quand je dis donc là dans
cette position on attend on attend
on attend la position exacte
donc
laurent réfléchi de toute façon laurent
doit jouer
les joueurs qui sont confortablement
installés ce doute absolument pas du
problème technique qui intervient à et
la partie va peut-être
interrompue non non non le technicien
sera walt voilà alors on a la position
maintenant c'est donc tout a été rétabli
c'est parfait donc
à partir de bombay 6 a probablement été
jouée après qu'avait après les changes
de dames oui mais ce n'est pas inscrit
dans la liste des coûts donc on le voit
sur l'échiquier mennessis le cavaly
revenant sur des deux puisqu'il ne sert
plus à rien en b3 et il va probablement
rebondir sur la case sekkat avec la
possibilité d'aller en 5 ou 3 voilà
exactement et dans cette position à les
blancs vont toujours essayé de pousser f
4 5 et d'obtenir quand même cette
majorité cette majorité au
à l'aller le roi mais évidemment michael
est très habituée
alors michael ils attaquent ce cavalier
blanc attention le fou est venu se
placer un e si cet accord cavalier blanc
qui va donc le faut aussi s'attaquer le
cavalier blanc en c4 qui va sans doute
reculer sur la case au taux de 3
c'est a priori le plus harmonieux
puisque c'est derrière un pion et la
case 3 oui souvent un cavalier comme ça
placé derrière un pion voilà donc
laurent qui continuent
comme d'habitude donc dans cette
position c5 donc les les noirs c'est de
la case des cinq mais en même temps il
permet alors cavaliers éventuellement
devenir sur des cats et toujours même un
peu venir ou suivre cette façon la cause
des saints qui est quand même très très
bien contrôlé donc
la position est tout à fait normal pour
l'instant disons les blancs un avantage
d'ouverture les traîtres est
microscopique et
bon ils ont un avantage stratégique à
long terme parce qu'ils ont des
meilleurs pions les noirs ils ont des
pions doublé en c'est cet essai
est donc ses deux pions
théoriquement ne remplissent le rôle que
d'un puisqu'ils sont sur la même colonne
et que pour aller à dame et il y en a un
qui va gêner l'autre même donc les
blancs eux ont vraiment 4 puis on contre
3 dont les pousser la dépouille en f4
puis e5 va à la longue sans doute créer
un pion livre ce que de l'autre côté et
noir et quatre pions noirs contre les
trois pions blancs sont incapables de
faire parce que parmi les quatre pions
noirs il y en a deux qui n'en valent
qu'un en fait mais la case des cats est
quand même très très importante c'est
une case qui va permettre au noir de de
respirer la colonne alors la casse des
cats et celle ci est une tour noire va
peut-être la tour nord va peut-être s'il
est une tour en tout cas c'est une case
bien contrôlé la colonne t et la colonne
eux sont ouvertes donc les noirs
pourront placer éventuellement pourront
jouer sur ces colonnes je ne sais pas je
pense que actuellement les choses sont
vraiment pas clair petit avantage blanc
mais mes petits petit oui car il ya un
facteur qui favorise un peu les noirs
c'est qu'ils ont un fou donc contraint
cavaliers on sait que dans ce genre de
positions assez ouverte où il ya du jeu
sur les deux ailes le faux est un peu
plus fort que lecavalier en tout cas il
ya quelque chose d'assez assez curieux
c'est que je me souviens des
confrontations l'année dernière entre
laurent frayssinet et alexei shirov et
c'est marrant c'est que laurent donc
jeune joueur est rentré exactement dans
le type de position qu'alexei
affectionne c'est à dire des positions
extrêmement tactique etc aujourd'hui
laurent toujours jeunes joueurs rentrent
dans des positions que michael adams
affectionne c'est à dire des positions à
long terme très très solide donc
voilà c'est une simple constatation veut
mettre peut-être son adversaire et
exagérément en confiance à chaque fois
peut-être la seule sur son propre
terrain ou peut-être que oui peut-être
que l'huile à l'excès d'optimisme il
pense qu'il peut jouer toujours sur le
terrain de son adversaire je ne sais pas
alors ça a évolué il ya eu deux coups de
pions le coup de pilon blanc f4 qui
avait menacé de repousser le fou et puis
le coût du pinot noir en effet 6 pour
donner sans doute cette case f7 de fuite
au fond
alors le rendre à accélérer laurendeau
accéléré il a 16 minutes et shiro des
fins que la dame cents à 22
donc il faut absolument qu'ils mettre le
turbo bon pour l'instant il ici c'est
pas encore trop tard mais messi minutes
déjà de retard à ce moment là le parti
c'est quand même un peu curieux pour
spécialistes de la variante oui c'est
vrai mais alors il ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'il ya quand même eu les changes
des dames les changes de 2 pièces
mineurs de chaque côté c'est quand même
assez simple à jouer et on peut jouer
des séries de coups très rapide dans une
fin de partie alors il a amené son roi
en f2 bien entendu donc on sait qu'en
fin de partie les rois joue un rôle
important un rôle actif et c'est plutôt
vers le centre qu'il faut donc les
places et maintenant adams réfléchit
c'est curieux parce que on a aurait
envie de placer la tour en plein centre
l'a hanté cats on voit pas trop ce qu'il
empêche de le faire
puisque les changes par les blancs tout
reprend tour serait catastrophique
puisque si après la venue de la tour
noirs les blancs font tout reprend tôt
il ya le pion noir qui prend les deux
cavaliers blanc fourchette avec
fourchette rappelons aux spectateurs
qu'une fourchette ces deux pièces en
prise par un pion ou par un cavalier 100
dollars de pièces qui fréquemment
peuvent défaire des comme ça des
attaques double
donc
une fourchette sur une grande assiette
donc voilà donc il s'est très ses traits
au noir dans cette position et donc tour
des cats et un coût possible ou et en
plus peut-être qu'il est noir vont
peut-être réagir aussi aller le roi
n'ont peut-être pas je ne sais pas en
tout cas les vos prêtres tout art
préparer la poussée du pion angers oui
c'est ça
h3 havas la tour descartes et le joue
quand même
hélas pour déloger cette tour ça ne va
pas être facile
pour laurent frayssinet parce que donc
on vient d'en parler là tournoi on peut
pas la prendre
il faudrait la chasse et avec un
cavalier mais si lecavalier ces trois
voiliers vient à eux deux eh bien le
pion e4 ne serais plus protégée et sans
doute adam se prendrait-il avec un
avantage quasiment décisif
par conséquent maintenant
laurent frayssinet semble un peu sur la
défensive les tours noir vont prendre le
contrôle de la colonne ouverte et ça
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour laurent
frayssinet
mauvaise oui mais bon n'oublions pas
quand même qu'il possède le sens très
peu l'ont donc la position est
équilibrée toujours toujours équilibré
mais et jean-luc cette colonne la seule
colonne ouverte aux situations les noirs
vont y placer leurs deux tours oui mais
par exemple je ne sais pas les blancs
peuvent jouer un coup comme h3 ils
peuvent pousser donc le pion h3 et sur
le doublement de
ne pas se soucier finalement de cette
avancée tour et continuer à pousser g4
par exemple
sur estimant que les deux tours en noir
finalement ne peuvent que c'est changer
ce qui n'est pas grave contre les tours
blanches oui bon mais c'est vrai que
peut-être que le plus sérieux ce serait
éventuellement de jouer un coup comme
tours tours tour des trois peut être
dans cette position de jouer la tour en
d3 pour éventuellement doublé aussi sur
la colonne des oui mais alors les noirs
pourraient prendre et le pion reprendre
en d3 et réoccuper sur la colonne visé
ce pions blancs par apple à un pion à
rire et à ce moment-là
longue réflexion de laurent frayssinet
ce qui prouve que cette tour noire
le gêne beaucoup
c'est bon
oui
alors il peut jouer peut-être
donc dans cette optique peut peut être
envisager de monter le roi en f3 pour
protéger le pion eu quatre de telle
manière ensuite au coude après à jouer
cavalier a eu deux attaques la tour
qu'il peut pas apprendre le piano capes
est une manoeuvre un peu un peu lente un
peu emberlificoté
le roi blanc se trouverait pour le coup
peut-être un peu en danger en f3
également
oui alors le handicap de temps de
laurent fois ci les va se creuser il
avait cinq minutes de retard
actuellement il doit être à peu près à 8
minutes de retard j'ai l'impression
et il manque de plans constructif parce
que les quatre pions qui font face aux
trois pions eh bien on a du mal
j'aime bien de source sûre que laurent à
12 minutes 44 et 20 minutes pour pour
michael adams dont huit minutes de
retard c'est beaucoup bref trois donc le
coût qui protège le pion central c'est
le seul coup qui permettent de bouger le
cavalier ses trois poursuivants il
pourra peut-être joué cavalier en e2
pour attaquer la tour noire met un coup
intéressant
mais michael ne s'en soucie pas
laurent doit se dépêcher
donc si je vous maintenant cavalier ou
deux attaquants la tour noire d'un
cavalier me donne un coup logique il
faut déloger cette tour qui a un avant
poste fantastique sur cette case sur
cette case malheureusement peut-être que
la tour va peut-être s'orienter sur la
case à 4 alors imaginons cavayé a eu
deux attaques la tour tour en a quatre
pions il faudrait le pouce et 1 à 3 et
cavaliers des quatre échecs et l'idée
est donc de jean-luc ses cavaliers des
quatre échecs il faudrait avec le
cavalier blanc ici prendre ce cavalier
noir et le pion noir se retrouverait en
d4 très belle position pour un pion en
place entre effectivement c'est pas très
bon pour les blancs de faire ça il
semble que laurent frayssinet doivent se
contenter à non voilà il se trouve le
cavalier ces trois ans des 5 c'est
intéressant ça obstrue la colonne
centrale où les tournois ne peuvent plus
maintenant entrer en liaison et sans
doute envisage-t-il au coup d'après de
pousser son pion maintenant libérés pour
attaquer la tour noire elle a délogé
très bonne idée nicolas parce que dans
cette position il est très important de
contrôler aussi la casse des cats qui
est une case sur laquelle pourraient
arriver à n'importe quel moment le
cavalier c6 laurent quand même fait un
bon choix en jouant ce coup c'est que
même s'il a plus beaucoup de temps il
décide un petit peu de compliquer la
position avec ses pièces puisque
stratégiquement les noirs auront l'air
quand même de bien maîtriser de bien
contrôler le centre donc voilà on va
voir ce que vont faire les noirs dans
cette position peut-être qu'ils vont
libérer la casse des cats tout de suite
par un coup de tours mais la tour la
source n'a pas vraiment de l'amour n'a
pas beaucoup de cavaliers des cinq est
destiné finalement c'est un coût qui est
fait pour dominer sa domine et à coup on
emploie souvent ces chèques pour dominer
la tour en d4 alors quand même il peut
jouer peut-être tour en a quatre
attaquants le pion à deux et sur a3 la
même idée que tout à leurs cavaliers
échec peut-être peut-être mais
peut-être mais je pense aussi un coup
spécial
non ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas je
pensais à f/5 mais aucun problème cinq
cavaliers un dessin qui est contrôlée
non pour à quatre c'est un coup très
intéressant puis on a trois et cavaliers
et chaque tournant autour de 8 à jouer
sur huit il prépare peut-être une
combinaison tactique à base de sacrifice
de tours non non ça semble un peu
pourquoi pas un peu fou alors imaginons
que les blancs jouent ces trois ça c'est
le coup logique ces trois attaques la
tour qu'est ce qui se passe sur ces
trois attaques la tour donc dans cette
position
elle devrait aller à gauche a priori
la lourdeur aia devrait aller en a
quatre la question est là on pousserait
sans doute saubion pour ne pas le perdre
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres choix
avec une position correcte et peut-être
que les noirs ont l'intention après de
capturer ce pion d'une façon ou d'une
autre peut-être avec franck cavallier
obligeant obligeant pions prend ce qui
serait peut-être pas très bon pour les
pions blancs oui puisqu'ils surtout
oui c'est à dire sept tours en d4 on
veut la dominer mais la question qu'on
peut se poser dans cette position c est
ce que la tour et domina bhl est ce
qu'on peut vraiment l'étouffer lui
empêcher de vivre d'avoir toujours des
cases je ne je n'en suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs
cette position donc lors on va essayer
en tout cas il va essayer de dominer
cette tour par ces trois alors la tour
donc la tour va sans doute aller sur la
gauche le sacrifice tout reprend pions
n'a pas l'air de marcher roi prend avec
sang froid et il n'y a pas de déchets
qu'elle a découvertes valable a priori
bien que oui donc il va sans doute jouer
tour en a quatre ou alors échanger les
tours mais ça c'est un peu leur en a
plus qu'un run en six minutes
actuellement dix minutes contre 18
minutes pour michael
michael est dix minutes je crois que
c'est encore un temps capital temps
correct parce que la fin de partie 3 4
donc pour faire vivre cette tour alors
là le pion vous voyez en a deux et
attaquer
il faut le défendre sans doute en le
poussant d'une case il ya donc à 2 à 3
probablement ou alors tour à 1 mais non
tout reims ça serait mon trop
fantaisistes ou alors est-ce qu'il peut
pas
non à 2 à 3 et comme tu l'as dit après
peut-être fou prendre des cinq puis on
prend des 5 et cavaliers bouge je ne
sais pas mais probablement sinon
peut-être les noirs peuvent attendre
peuvent différer la présenter cinq par
à-coups comme g5 alors il a joué le coup
à a3 effectivement il a poussé son pion
pour pas le perdre et maintenant le coût
plausible des noirs ça serait d'attaquer
ce pion blanc par un coup de fusil un
coup de fouet peut-être un profond et
xavier peut-être en reculant à vii aussi
car comment le protéger ce pion qui
seraient attaqués après c'est plus
facile les noirs ont joué tour 8 très
très rapidement et on remarque comme
d'habitude que c'est un coup
positionnelle de qualité puisqu'il vise
un pion qui étaient vendus uniquement
par le roi et qui peut être au prix donc
laurent va devoir justifier justifié
probablement il va peut-être le
sacrifier ce pion au total six ans qu'il
est en difficulté mais pour les noirs il
ya beaucoup de fous dangereux fouan fois
êtes on vous en g8 carrément même en
dix-sept peut-être fou décès dont ils
écoutent où tout ce qui peut être à quel
point on peut être très bon dans cette
position mais parce qu'il faut voir
aussi que sur fief celle qui a peut-être
le coup cavaliers f5 attaquant depuis
angers 7 ce genre de choses
qui est possible voilà peut-être il va
jouer là cavalier f5 sacrifié depuis un
local pour prendre le plan g7 et puis
après le pion f6 très faible ça semble
quand même assez assez assez douteux ans
j'ai du mal à croire dans cette
manoeuvre de cavaliers mais quoi d'autre
mais peut-être quelque chose d'un peu
plus compact je ne sais pas peut-être
sacrifier ce pion aux quatre pour
obtenir du jeu je ne sais pas comment
pour l'instant mais
cavalli f5 quand même assez particulier
par exemple son cavalier f5 que se
passerait-il après donc tout reprend
tout reprend alors cavaliers f5 ont fait
le coup tout reprend 40 cadres cavaliers
étrangers 7 voilà donc dans cette
position
dans cette position oui peut-être
moins peut-être peut-être qu'on peut
jouer sa cavalière alors sur cavani f5
que se passerait-il a pris un coup comme
g6 alors j'ai six il y aurait cavaliers
g3 pour cavaler j'ai trois
cavaliers g3 peut-être peut-être c'est
peut-être la seule solution et il faut
trouver des abonnés nous mêmes à une
astuce tactique sur 4,5 g 6,6 à
cavaliers pro b 6 échecs d'accord dans
cavaliers cinq bons coups insurgés si
cela regardez la menace ses cavaliers
prend b6 et chaque angle et cavaliers
des six cents qu'avaient les des six
échecs ça prend enfin je sais pas si
c'est une vraie menace mais ça fait peur
donc la position recèle quand même des
noms là maintenant la menace ses
cavaliers des six échecs voilà la vraie
menace puis on prend cavaliers prend b6
échec comprend l'autre tour mais est ce
que est ce que est ce que les conduire
des facteurs pratique de la partie c'est
à dire 8 minutes pour laurent contre 16
minutes pour adams
sont vraiment raisonnable dans ce type
en huit minutes c'est quand même c'est
beaucoup encore beaucoup c'est beaucoup
par rapport au capital dans de quatre
chefs tout à l'heure c'est vraiment
énorme qui achète lui dans ce genre de
situation quand il restait assez peu de
matériel lui il avait deux minutes même
pas
oui donc grâce et raisonnable je pense
que c'est raisonnable pression du temps
pour le renforcer il faut espérer il
faut espérer pour que alors regardez la
menace est quand même très jolie a
menacé cavaliers des six échecs puis on
prend cavaliers pro b 6 échecs roi
bessette mettons cavaliers prend 1,4
alors c'est pas fini parce que les noirs
peuvent contre-attaqué pas fou b3 avec
attac de la touvre et du cavalière
et une ligne amusante oh oui les
cavaliers vont faire une fourchette
haute armés
peut-être bouger si souci dans cette
position fou g6 immédiatement pour
attaquer le curieux 4
je ne sais pas alors fou g6
immédiatement à un oui mais est-ce que
ça ne part pas la menace cavell
cavaliers des six échecs cavaliers des
six échecs puis on prend et cavaliers
pro b 6
ça ne part pas mais les cavaliers se
retrouvera mal placés en en 1 à 4 c est
très compliqué après roy ses sept
cavaliers prend à 4 pouces et 2 et le
cavalier est enfermé mais bon
la position est encore tendue je pense
que il c'était une position très
importante adams va pas mal réfléchir à
ce moment là pour pour trouver la
meilleure défense et je pense qu'il
trouvera la meilleure défense donc
espérons que la position puisque je
pense que dans cette pression il faut
quand même un petit peu inespéré il ya
des facteurs autres que purement
technique il faut espérer que même si
adams trouver la meilleure défense la
position quand même soit correcte pour
les blancs et lui permettre peut-être de
gagner je sais pas alors c'est une
partir duquel caractéristiques de
laurent frayssinet qui adore manoeuvre
avec ses cavaliers avec ses cavaliers il
fait des espèces de sarabande avec un
petit gic auteurs
notamment quand il a les pièces noires
il joue la défense comme la défense
nîmes zollitsch là où il ya les
cavaliers noirs qui luttent contre des
foules blanc il est très très fort
d'ailleurs est ce qu'ils ont vu qu'il
n'avait pas battu les museaux vite non
il m'a jamais je les mets au vici joue
il joue surtout la semi slave contre moi
oui mais il a joué de manière très
tactique c'est très curieux parce qu'il
a un répertoire de vue routier et tout
et puis là comme on vous le voyez vous
cette position toujours des petites
finesse un jeu de pièces très tactique
mais bon c'est pas étonnant dans ce type
d'ouverture puisque finalement la
structure est simple et le jeu de piste
fait la différence dans ce type de
position alors le coup un peu disons
peureux pour michael adams a serait de
faire feu prend cavaliers champions en
grand et bouger le cavalier mais là
encore il y aurait quand même un
avantage aux blancs puis ce qui menace
de plonger cette fois l'oublier
donc non il est apparemment
obligé michael adams
de jouer ou comme
événement il faut quand même protégé
vous êtes donc
un ou
comme g6 alors il faudrait tant pis
laisser faire la menace la soi disant
menace des blancs
de fourchette avec les cavaliers et qui
ne marcherait pas à cause de la fin du
four b3 il ya plein d'astuces par
exemple imagine nicolas ce que les noirs
dans cette position jouffroy bessette si
les atours pro à 4 tours pro 4 donc
alors là cavalier prend cavaliers pros
spéciales et cavaliers prendre b6 échec
est jouable aussi mais sans doute risqué
sur cavaliers pro b 6 peut-être que dans
cette position les noirs doivent tout
simplement eu le roi bouger le roi en
bessette et attaquer le cavalier
l'autre alternative donc le terme
une sarabande des cavaliers voilà ce que
j'annonce et voilà les petits coups de
cavaliers
roi bessette le coût normal donc leur
offre aussi des doit avoir à peu près
sept minutes actuellement alors que
michael en a 13
et là il peut jouer à nouveau une
sarabande de cavaliers regarde jean luc
cavaliers 17 menaces cavaliers français
cinq cavaliers des cfc fabuleux c'est
fantastique déchaînés et cabaye
laurent jacqua que huit minutes et 13
minutes à adams c'est un coût qui est
quand même assez assez désagréable huit
minutes pour
freyssinet c'est 13 minutes pour adams
mais de grosses menaces pour le français
qui menace de prendre le pion à ses 5
avec fourchette au roi noir et à la tour
noire
est jean-luc va nous montrer tous vos
deux tours 2 et donkey la fourchette qui
était kim qui menaçait le cabinet menacé
venir en c5 donc les noirs jouent ici
mais les blancs vont prendre le pire en
c5 et avoir une position très supérieure
oui on le rend facile mais exactement il
mais maintenant il faut accélérer
laurent accélère laurent
lacets adams qui est un échec au roi
donc il va venir en b6 très certainement
voir en un set peut-être dans b 6e
semble plus
plus actif
et là laurent fois ci ne peux tout
simplement jouer b4 qu'est ce que tu en
penses dans l'ue pour qu'elle joue
cavalier enlève le pion de la taille de
la tour
peut-être
limonov cavaliers 17 et chaque wii
menace éventuellement des cas les décès
tgv il faut se méfier parce que dans
cette position bekkat et le trait et le
chemin du roy vers les pions vers les
pions blancs est tout tracé
pas se faire mater ce roi qui s'il
avance trop peut-être mais si on joue b4
lui laisse des cases de fuite donc il
faut faire très attention c'est
peut-être pas la meilleure décision
peut-être que cavaliers des cet échec
oui et leroy revient et on essaye de
trouver un truc parce que le but dans
cette position c'est d'échanger une de
ses paires de cette tour pour finalement
éliminer toutes les contre sens tactique
que peuvent avoir les noirs alors il ya
aussi des astuces du style carré 17
échec suivi de cavaliers ou 5
interceptant les deux tours pour
capturer une des deux tours oui mais
malheureusement à chaque cavalier ou 5
il ya cavaliers prend 1,5 donc qu'à
valider cet échec robes et sept
cavaliers aux cinq cavaliers prend 1,5
roy prend tour est fou échec et la tour
et récupérer donc
voilà c'est assez linéaire bon je vais
un petit peu vite mais c'est des choses
un truc la grosse attaque pour le
français qui semble en mesure d'égaliser
au score et qui a toujours son pion de
toujours un pion de plus
donc sa majorité de le reconduire sa
majorité elle est le roi est passé à l'
aile dame par magie ouais grâce à ces
cavaliers fou
donc laurent n'a plus que 6 minutes et
c'est et 12 minutes pour michael laurent
fau qui s'inquiètent pour le temps là
effectivement je pense qu'il est prêt
pour s'entendre en suisse
oui c'est ensemble donc lui oui
donc et le coupé 4 me plaît malgré tout
tu aimes le coupé car j'aimerais quand
même mater le roi quelque part voilà
et gagner le pion à 6 aussi si le roi
montaut
ok
donc l'auront
en pleine réflexion
il peut jouer aussi tout simplement tour
en un an il peut pas elle qui a valu à
attaquer je disais une bêtise il peut
jouer donc validé cet échec et voilà une
qui a validé cette suivi ce avec
solidité de tours f2 peut-être
alors la question est ce que michael
michael réfléchi entre montées sont rois
pour se rapprocher de ses pions faible
faible mais prendre des risques énormes
ou tout simplement
attendre un petit peu et fait venir où
il était on puisque le cavalier en 17 et
pas très bien placé actuellement mais
mais les pions et tous les pions on dire
les pions les pions g7 son emprise donc
comme je l'expliquais tout à l'heure en
échangeant une des deux tours noirs les
blancs vont obtenir un net avantage
oui les intentions de laurent frayssinet
peut-être tout simplement maintenant de
jouer très solides par tour f2 ou plus
ou coup suivant pour neutraliser une
tour noire la tour noire la plus
dangereuse eh bien il a neutralisé par
tous rêvent de robes et 7 donc on va
voir la hesse qui jouent tous rêvent 2
ça me semble le plus raisonnable ici
tous rêvent 2 mais attention tout rêve
de tout rêve de fou h 5 échecs et roy g3
tous rêvent deux fois cinq échecs mais
si roy j'ai trois tours prend tout roi
prend touré fou prend tour à houla
j'attends surtout ref deux fous h 5
échecs g4 fou pranger 4 oui ça j'ai vu
mais la tour derrière et la partie est
gagnée pour les noirs dans tous rêvent
de n'est pas le bon coup donc peut-être
dans cette position il faut par exemple
jouer cavalier revient sûr j'ai trois
tours échec est roi et deux peut-être un
truc plus comme ça mais mais dans ces
cas là le pion g7 n'est plus en prise et
les tours reste les tournois en plus
donc dans cette position que vont faire
les que vont faire les noirs les blancs
7 aux blancs d'où ils vont jouer
cavalier projet set peut-être malgré
tout donc cavalier proches 17 mai
cavaliers projet sont la tour cavalli
projet 7 est très très dangereux
moi j'ai trois ça c'est un coup
surprenant
surprenant ça laisse le pion b2 emprise
ça c'est curieux à pour jouer tour b 1
peut-être surtout reprend b de nom
qu'est ce qu'il va faire
moi j'ai trois est encore une petite
astuce de le lot de laurent c'est à dire
sur moi j'ai trois tours prend b2 il
fait cavalier le roi ne veut pas venir
en b 6 à cause de cavaliers c'est 5 à 4
fourchette entre le roi et la tour donc
il faut autour des 7 au coup d'après
donc et après cavaliers échec évidemment
il pourra monter cette tour sur la
septième rangée
donc voilà les
rochers 3 et un coût qui est destiné
finalement à mettre le roi un peu plus
en sécurité quand à eux trois mais
il ya le coup j'essaie jesse ce nom qui
n'est pas gênant le en panne si c'est
pas ce n'est pas gênant fou g6 il a joué
ou g6 c'est peut-être plus sérieux
et là est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer qui
avait les projets set quand même
cavalier prend g7 est extrêmement risqué
je pense dans cette position parce que
sur cavaliers prend g7 probablement tour
touché huit cavaliers cavalli t4 on veut
changer les pièces il veut simplifier un
petit peu la position mais
malheureusement
après cavaliers prend des quatre tours
prend des quatre peut-être que
maintenant on peut prendre le plan b
devant le pion en b2
il veut peut-être joué à ce moment là et
changer les tour par tour b 4 échecs
pour remettre ses pions en ordre donc
michael semble avoir neutralisé le jeune
laurent qui avait quand même récupérer
100 millions de moins michael oui oui
bon toujours quelques possibilités
d'attaqué pour les blancs quand même il
faut toujours se méfier par exemple le
coût le coup surprenant
f5 qui est vraiment en particulier mais
qui permettait attaqué le pion g7 exacte
et qui sait gagner de l'espace qui
serait assez actif dans cette position
lui c'est à dire le la poussée de pions
f5 peut-être mais sur f5 il y à tours 3
attention attention la voilà il regroupe
ses pions en proposant un échange de
tours comme ça il aura deux beaux pions
lié à l'ale dame et la case ses 5 pour
son cavalier case idéal malheureusement
le rohan bessette est idéalement placé
pour jouer cette finale puisqu'il est
prêt à se rapprocher de tous ses pions
le roi est très très mal placée pour
pour pour avoir un rôle actif dans la
finale la position du roi est très très
importante dans les finales il semble
que michael adams et égaliser les
chances là et semble pouvoir faire nul
mais ce n'est pas fini
car le cavalier de frayssinet dans la
phase blitz va être redoutable annoncé
jean-luc que les cavaliers quand il ya
peu de temps peuvent faire des miracles
les cavaliers font des bonds miraculeux
oui exactement donc on combien
reste-t-il de temps aux joueurs ils
toujours six minutes d'écart 3 minutes
22 pour le rencontre 9 21 ans pour
michael donc difficile et voilà michael
qui se débarrasse de son pur isolé et
peut-être ce genre de final
devient même techniquement difficile
pour les noms pour les blancs puisque
puisque eux puisque le roi vous est plus
fort que le cavalier le fou est plus
fort que le cavalier et le roy est très
bien placé parce qu'après les changes
des pions le roi n'a plus qu'une case
affaires à parcourir avant de pouvoir
prendre le petit pion est là laurent
même si il aime bien faire bondir ses
cavaliers il falloir qu'il trouve des
des bons miraculeux donc
la partie se passe mal actuellement
c'est dommage puisque puisque vous êtes
là où il avait une bonne opposition très
intéressante avec des coûts de cavaliers
vraiment très très
une bonne partie une très bonne partie
alors maintenant michael adams a
certainement et c'est gagné le pion b4
des blancs peut-être en échangeant
d'abord où on joue au roi b5
immédiatement
donc
il faut jouer dans cette position
laurent doit jouer il doit hésiter
michael adams assez à michael de jouer
et disait hésité à jouer très très
solide
ne rien faire pour se contenter de la
nulle ou attaquer je pense que michael
dans une opposition veut augmenter son
avantage une raison x f7 peut-être l'as
rome pour remettre son fou en plein
centre en d5
c'était pas mal sous puisque bon michael
joue pour la la pureté de la position
dans cette position il faut chercher les
meilleurs coups toujours cette finale
technique peut toujours
lui rendre service donc tu penses
tu pensé appeler le fouet remettre le
fou en 2g 600 f 16 pour voilà mais il le
fait
voilà les pions s'échanger
mais c'est bien vu tout un la
tour-blanche redevient active j'ai passé
ça sera suffisant mais en tout cas elle
a un peu de jeu elle peut venir mais
peuvent venir sur certaines cases mai le
four des cinq aussi est très actif sans
doute le roi noir va-t-il s'avancer pour
attaquer le pion blanc
en bessac ouais je redoute ce coup pour
laurent parce qu'ensuite il pourra
pousser son plan de ses 7 ans et 6 pour
consolider le fou il peut vraiment
voir l'avenir avec
ou l' attaque avec la tour c'est encore
plus direct encore plus direct
exactement mais surtour à 4 il a prévu
peut-être deux tours et chaque tour b 6
c'est presque mat le roi noir ce qu'il
veut fuir n'a qu'une kcb sein qui peut
aussi interposés la tour
tour b6 et maintenant tu pourras 4
mai
après tour à quatre peut-être tout
simplement où tour à cette voie la tour
prend il ya tour français cet échec car
avec un cavalier qui tournoient encore
un petit coup de cavaliers
encore une fourchette
il a vraiment un bon coup de fourchette
malgré ces en apparence plutôt plutôt
maigre donc
fou c4 est probablement la parade idéale
ce type de position donc fou ces quatre
pour éviter surtout pro b 4 le coutour
procès sept et si on reprend ses sept
cavaliers et chaque adepte cette
transaction
oui puisque de toute façon son but cette
sphère nul et que dans cette position
lors on ne peut rien démontré avec six
minutes de moins à la pendule à il peut
jouer et peut tourner avec son cavalier
c'est maintenant qu'ils lui qui a une
légèrement des 24 pour leur encontre
c'est lui qui a une position légèrement
meilleur maintenant cavalier est à
l'aise quand tout va se jouer d'un seul
côté de l'échiquier tout va se jouer à
droite donc le cavalier va tournoyer on
est en blitz après tout il n'a rien à
perdre et il va le faire tournoyer son
cavalier j'en suis sûr et on va avoir un
spectacle amusant voilà il met tout sur
les cases noires pour empêcher que le
fou et fassent la moindre menace et
maintenant il va cambadélis joyeusement
avec lecavalier oui mais voilà en e2 et
pof le coup d'après ça sera en d4 enfin
bon on fantasme un petit peu quand même
dans la cabine on y croit quand même
voilà et voilà on sait jamais on se doit
du pays
le problème c'est qu'après g5 h4 les
pions s'échange vite mais michael a
n'est pas pressé il attend le dernier
moment pour le faire alors le cavalier
va aller en b 4 pour chasser le roi
c'est peut-être ou alors non il cherche
sa voie mais la fougue quatre ans fou 4
et le cavalier 2 impasse des lilas h4h 4
évidemment il ne fait pas vraiment
progressé de l'opposition laurent
frayssinet mais
n'ayant rien à perdre après tout allez
on joue cavalier bien vite vite
il va perdre autant là
une minute 52 pour laurent
canton 5 minutes 20 c'est vraiment
c'est trop dur
et là c'est à quitte ou et j'arrive pas
à voir j'ai manqué le dernier coup
jean-luc assez haut noir de jouer il
veut échanger tous les pions oui c'est
ce que j'avais prévu tout à l'heure j'ai
5 h 5 h 4 il faut il changer tous les
pions et quand il reste plus qu'un
cavalier est un fou aux échecs la partie
est nul mais il peut pas échanger tous
les pions en échange et deux sur trois
oui mais malheureusement il aura plus qu
à sacrifier le fou contrôle dernier
fleurs la voilà le roi blanc gagne une
case il va monter le roi blanc sans
doute
pour gagner un peu de terrain
mais non ils jouent pas et va
voilà il a réussi à éviter les change
d'option n'y a plus eu qu'un seul pion
de chaque côté échange et ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour roland freyssinet
oui pour l'instant il est assez malin il
peut il menacer cavaliers des quatre qui
gagne est un fou au f5 tout à l'heure et
voilà maintenant ils passent sur les
cases noires et son roi il arrive à
augmenter un petit peu sont peut-être
cavaliers des cinq avec un piège encore
mais qui ne fonctionne pas vraiment là
il propose à ses astuces et aussi
quoique ya le coup droit noir qui
peuvent bien f5 royal 5 est très
ennuyeux là mais ça semble finie oui la
ceni 3,5 et
ouais il n'y a plus rien à faire ici et
repèrent un pion
c'est les noirs même qu'ils vont gagner
voilà on a par cas l'explication de
michael à la physique
un style sobre et efficace
oui donc
alors bon laurent a tout essayé dans
cette partie
malheureusement bon michael adams a joué
4 5 une espagnole qui est une ouverture
assez solide donc il a tenu tenu cette
position apparemment assez facilement
donc michael adams gagne le match on va
voir tout de suite qu en pense ce qu'en
pensent les joueurs alors ok mais by
laurent un petit mot est ce que tu
penses que tu as eu des chances de gain
dans cette partie où la défense a été
trop solide je pense qu'il a très bien
joué dans cette partie très bon en
défense toute façon je pense j'ai jamais
été mieux sauf peut-être un moment où il
a commencé à mon avis à faire quelques
coups imprécis et j'ai peut-être eu des
chances comme un guerrier et et par là
mais j'ai pas vu j'ai pas eu ce que je
pouvais faire non mais j'ai un thema
chances d'un point un parti c'est clair
donc pour toi le match a basculé dans la
première partie et dans la deuxième il y
avait plus de plus de solutions pour ce
pour revenir non évidemment il ya des
solutions mais ils ont qu'il a bien
verrouillé et après j'ai c'est quand
même assez dur de battre un joueur aussi
fort
effectivement donc rappelons quand même
que michael adams et numéro 7 mondial ça
veut dire qu'il ya que six joueurs plus
fort que lui dans le monde tout
simplement donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même une référence alors sow
michael tomorrow is you play against
joël lautier force finale
so what 1 voir
justin match
d'accord donc la dernière fois que
michael adams a joué contre joël lautier
en partie rapide c'est joël lautier qui
l'avait emporté donc effectivement ça va
être un match difficile difficile pour
les deux joueurs de toute façon on peut
pas en dire vraiment plus si ce n'est
que bon ici laurent a tenté sa chance
demain il aura une de nouveau un
adversaire extrêmement fort en velay
19,4 chef à partir de 20 heures à 22
heures la finale ou 22h 22h30 à partir
de 22 heures la finale de ce quatrième
édition du grand prix de bordeaux suivie
par la remise des prix donc michael
adams contre joël lautier donc je vous
invite à revenir demain est en tout cas
merci d'avoir suivi cette ce spectacle
et je vous souhaite une bonne soirée
[Musique]
nous
je
[Musique]
ça avance
joel le titre
et michael adams et la finale des
perdants comme mon ami pelade est mon
ennemi laurent non c'est une blague donc
laurent qui
a vraiment fait une bonne prestation
quand même puisqu'il a très bien joué
les deux parties il n'a pas eu de chance
et puis bon michael est quand même une
meilleure technique mais quand même dans
la deuxième partie il a un moment il a
donné quand même l'impression d'avoir
d'avoir des chances de gains après ces
petites manoeuvres de cavaillé et tout
[Musique]
joël lautier orale et blanc dans la
première contre michael adams et laurent
frayssinet aura également les blancs
contre vladislav quatre chefs donc ça va
être chaud ce match demain oui
évidemment
évidemment chaussée c'est vrai que bon
alors on a quand même beaucoup de
ressources on l'a vu aujourd'hui dans
son match contre michael adams bon le
petit le petit jeune de dax notre local
de l'épreuve est quand même très
talentueux mais maintenant je vais
interroger le numéro 1 français j'aurais
donc je vais le tuer a battu vladislav
tkachiev numéro un mondial c'est déjà
une belle performance et comment tu
abordes le match demain contre michael
c'est à dire ça que je connais bien donc
je sais pas on va voir quoi j'ai pas
j'ai pas de stratégie particulière pour
l'instant
j'espère que je vais faire des bonnes
parties et pourquoi oui pourquoi tu
choisis les noirs en fait quand tu as le
choix contre vladislav tkachiev dans la
première partie et est ce que demain à
voir les blancs dans la première ça va
déstabiliser où ça va changer ta
stratégie de match mais si tu veux c'est
le mot c'est la décision la plus
courante parce que ça permet de voir
venir un peu c'est un peu comme au
football on préfère jouer le match
revanche à la maison quoi c'est un petit
peu la même chose ici quand on allait
dans l'année en partie en un peu plus de
marge de manoeuvre si on a perdu la
première on sait qu'on peut on peut tout
donner avec et blanc alors que la
première partie quand on a les blancs on
peut pas non plus tout en voyant le tout
envoyé parce que si on perd on sait
traduire d'égaliser les quais noirs
voilà quoi c'est mon enfance a fait pour
une très très grosse différence pas une
grosse différence donc demain confiant
et on va te laisser aller de préparer
pour un match difficile donc merci joël
et bonne bon match demain merci à demain
voilà donc le direct le direct continue
puisque puisqu'il ya des queues des
fanas des chèques ici jean-luc chavanon
va nous faire quelques quelques
commentaires dans la lumière dans la
lumière de ce théâtre fémina
alors jean-luc de menthe et pronostic
est ton analyse
déjà sur sur la finale je lautier contre
vladislav contre michael adams donc
c'est une finale qui promet qui promet
donc les deux joueurs qui sont très
expérimentés vont vont jouer des parties
donc qu'ils allaient blanc dans la
première série michael adam szalai blanc
dans la première joël le ciel et blanc
donc probablement joué elle va je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas il va jouer des
quatre quatre c4 ils jouent tous donc
michael est un joueur de nîmes the beach
très très solide comme on l'a vu
aujourd'hui et donc la partie va être
qu'on va dire chacun va imposer son
style mais probablement on aura le droit
encore une partie longue tendu
ou le temps va jouer également
dans la revanche on aura probablement
droit à eux quatre puisque michael ne
change change très peu donc je ne sais
pas exactement mais pronostics puisque
je ne sais pas exactement ce que je joue
elle sur quatre à son dernier tournoi il
a beaucoup joué face à d4 donc la
surprise reste totale sur sa préparation
donc les deux joueurs semblent très très
déterminée et je pense que il y aura du
beau spectacle en ce qui concerne la
finale des perdants
donc probablement encore donc vlada les
noirs la première donc eu quatre avec
les blancs alors là vlad peut tout jouer
il peut probablement jouer une défense
pire que quatre ou cinq ou aussi une
scandinaves qui sont ces ouvertures
fétiche donc là il va probablement jouer
l'ouverture qui correspondent mieux à
son adversaire qui correspond le moins
bien à son adversaire et dans la
revanche
on s'attend pour le moins une défense là
vous peut-être une anglaise puisqu'il a
joué l anglaise aujourd'hui donc je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas mais laurent a
vraiment été très très impressionnant
aujourd'hui il n'a pas eu trop de chance
donc cela doit vraiment se méfier vlad a
plus d'expérience mais il va vraiment se
méfier et ça sera aussi un beau
spectacle pour ce début de soirée
d'accord alors pour conclure pour
conclure ce direct sur canal web
diagonale et tous les sites diffuseur
jean-luc je vais te demande et donc je
vais vous mettre internationale je vais
demander un pronostic ferme qui va
gagner demain
un pronostic ferme
après avoir le pronostic soft le
pronostic servent disons que
les deux joueurs sont mes amis je vais
faire un ennemi moi je peux pas répondre
sans pareil bon on va être chauvin on va
dire que joël va gagner demain mais
bon c'est joël c'est joël d'accord donc
le coup de coeur de jean luc chabanon
personnellement je ne me prononcerai pas
puisque puisque c'est effectivement un
choix très difficile donc je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce direct je vous
donne rendez vous demain à 20 heures de
20h à 1h du matin c'est inclura la
remise des prix et s'inclura bien
entendu la finale exceptionnelle de ceux
de ce quatrième grand prix de bordeaux
trophée clc assurance dans le théâtre
fémina à bordeaux merci